Ihr hört, CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft, mein Name ist Tim Brittlov und ich begrüße alle hier zur zweihundertvierundzwanzigsten Ausgabe von CAYE.
Und äh ja ja, heute gibt es mal wieder eine dieser seltenen äh Fortsetzungssendung. Es gibt natürlich verschiedenste Themen, die ich hier in den letzten,
16 Jahren mal angesprochen habe, die in irgendeiner Form fortgesetzt werden sollten, nicht alle werden vielleicht diese Segnung erfahren. Aber bei diesem Thema ist definitiv so viel passiert.
Man hier das Ganze nochmal neu aufrollen muss und konkret dreht es sich um das Thema elektronisches Geld,
Was in CAE einhundertundzweiundachtzig am haltet euch fest, zwölften Juni zwanzig,
11 des Licht der Welt erblickte und damals sprach ich mit Andreas Burg.
Und genauso werde ich es heute halten. Hallo Andreas.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei CAE, denn äh ja, wir sind uns einig, dieses Thema braucht jetzt nach mittlerweile zehn Jahren dann doch mal dringend ein Update, zehn, zehneinhalb Jahren
äh ist schon ist schon wirklich auch eine eine Menge passiert und wie wir auch gleich hören werden, irgendwie auch nicht. Also ähm schnallt euch an. Also wir wollen über
Die generelle Problematik, Geldtransfer in irgendeiner Form in den digitalen Welt darzustellen sprechen.
Letztes Mal haben wir äh dazu erstmal, ich mache mal so eine kleine ähm Zusammenfassung vielleicht, worüber wir letztes Mal geredet haben, wie in sozusagen die Details,
äh interessieren, seid ihr natürlich herzlich eingeladen auch nochmal in die Sendung
reinzuhören. Ich hab's ja auch noch mal neu äh nachgeschnitten und mit ähm einem Transkript versehen. So ähm anlässlich der Fortsetzung
ja wir haben äh so ein bisschen darüber geredet, was so die ersten Versuche waren, Geld zu digitalisieren, das war nämlich e-cash.
Eine Idee, die im Prinzip so dem Gedanken gefolgt
ist, dass man ja vielleicht die Münzen in irgendeiner Form digital repräsentieren soll. Also man ging so ein bisschen vom Bargeld aus und auch so von diesen Features vom Bargeld, nicht, dass man's möglichst anonym halten sollte
Und irgendwie,
gab's zwar verschiedene Ansätze, die aber dann sowohl an Lizensierungsfragen, aber auch an ganz konkreten technischen Höhen gescheitert sind. Und am Ende gab's zwar den ein oder anderen experimentellen Versuch,
so richtig funktioniert hat es eigentlich nicht,
Und dann haben wir eigentlich den Rest der Sendung im Wesentlichen über den zweiten, vier großen Versuch gesprochen, nämlich Bitcoin.
Und während halt E-Cashes mit so digitalen Münzen probiert hat ähm wurde bei Bitcoin eigentlich so eine Art dezentrale Buchhaltung
eingeführt, in der halt einfach erfasst wird, WM denn jetzt welches Geld gehört und damit das irgendwie zuverlässig stattfinden kann,
kommt hier sehr viel Kryptografie zum Einsatz. Das war der die Geburtsstunde der Blockchain,
eine ja ewige Liste von Transaktionen,
regelmäßig immer wieder bestätigt werden muss und in so einem verteilten Netzwerk so eine Konsensbildung betreibt, in dem halt viele Computer die ganze Zeit
versuchen mathematische Aufgaben zu lösen, was sehr schwierig ist und wenn sie das dann getan haben
können sie diese Zwischenergebnisse benutzen, um eben weitere Einträge in dieser ewigen Liste vorzunehmen. Und es war.
Ganz interessant. Also als wir das Gespräch letztes Mal hatten.
War die Blockchain also die komplette Blockchain, das was sozusagen vollständig alle Transaktionen des Netzwerks erfasst 500 Megabyte groß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du auswendig weißt, wie groß äh die Blockchain von Bitcoin derzeit ist.
Das weiß ich auswendig nicht, aber ein bisschen größer ist sie geworden, ja.
Auf jeden Fall handelt es sich hier um hunderte von äh Gigabytes. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich auch glatt vorher nochmal nachschlagen können. Wie groß jetzt eigentlich wirklich ist, aber
da ist auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge passiert und wächst halt unauffällig an, also das ist sozusagen diese ganze verteilte Datenbank, über die sich die ganze Welt mittlerweile da drüber verständigt.
Dreihundertachtundfünfzig Gigabyte Stand Oktober zweitausendeinundzwanzig.
Dreihundertachtundfünfzig Gigabyte. Und hast du auch noch ein Gefühl dafür, äh wie viel ein Bitcoin so wert war auf dem freien Markt?
Oh, zweitausendelf, ich erinnere mich, dass ich äh
ich habe 2tausend011 ein paar Bitcoins gemeint und dann verkauft für ich glaube 5 Euro das Stück und wir haben für null Komma zwei Bitcoin äh im Room seventy seven ähm zwei Burger und vier Bier gehabt.
Null Komma zwei Bitcoin. Ja, vor allem hast du mir in der Sendung live null Komma null zwei Bitcoin sozusagen deine two sand äh übertragen.
Äh damals war auf Mount Gocks äh ein eine eine Website, die es nicht mehr gibt äh für ungefähr 20 US-Dollar gehandelt.
Das heißt, die null Komma null zwei Bitcoin, die du mir geschickt hast, waren zu Hochzeit tausend Euro wert.
Insofern vielen Dank. Das war eine sehr angenehme Bezahlung für so eine Sendung.
Das das kommt drauf an, wie lange du sie aufgehoben hast.
Ich hab's natürlich genau im richtigen Zeitpunkt verkauft. Wer hat das schon gemacht?
Tatsächlich habe ich irgendwann nochmal äh irgendeine alte Wallet von der Platte gekratzt und so die äh das Geld ab der dritten Nachkommastelle ähm äh noch mal verkauft für gutes Geld. Also,
ich beschwere mich nicht. Ich ähm bin nett positiv rausgekommen aus der ganzen Nummer.
Ja, also
und überhaupt ähm gab's glaube ich eine ganze Menge Leute, die einfach Kraft früher äh Bitcoin-Experimente, die damals ja wirklich noch so ein Nerd-Hobby waren ähm sicherlich
haben profitieren können, manche mehr, manche weniger, manche sind immer noch auf Müllhalden unterwegs und suchen nach ihren alten Festplatten oder schauen durch ihre Archive, ob sie das Passwort für die Wallet dann äh doch noch vielleicht irgendwo herausfinden können.
Ja, aber ähm das das war das war die Zeit und ähm wir haben halt ähm versucht zu erläutern, was es mit diesem Proof of Work äh auf sich hat, dass also die Maschinen mehr oder weniger immer so an der Belastungsgrenze
kalkuliert, Zeit verbrauchen müssen, immer um diesen nächsten Block signieren zu können,
Daran hat sich im Wesentlichen nichts geändert. Ich habe mir noch so ein paar,
Aussagen, Sätze, die in der Sendung gefallen sind notiert. Äh du meintest auch, noch lohnt es sich, wenn man die passende Grafikkarte hat?
Später waren dann keine Grafikkarten mehr äh im Einsatz. Heute ist das schon wieder so, ne?
Ja wir sind äh ein bisschen full Circle gekommen, ne. Also es äh ging dann von den Grafikkarten weiter zu FPGAs, Leute haben sich FPGA Cluster gebaut, um da drauf zu rechnen. Dann ging's weiter mit speziellen Chips. Asics, die genau dafür gemacht wurden, Bitcoin zu meinen.
Und äh mittlerweile fallen durch die Explosionen der verschiedenen äh elektronischen Geldsysteme.
Sind wir wieder da gelandet, dass man aufm freien Markt keine Grafikkarten mehr kaufen kann. Äh
kennen das, ähm weil die auch wieder zu tausenden äh in äh in Mining Recks verbaut werden.
Mhm. Genau äh wir hatten uns dann eigentlich äh verabredet, dass wir dann nach dem Crash nochmal äh miteinander reden wollen.
Kann man drüber rätseln, ob's den gab oder nicht, also in gewisser Hinsicht gab's ihn nicht, weil das System ist ja immer noch da.
Gab ihn aber auch schon, weil es jetzt auch nicht so ist, dass äh wir jetzt hier so eine permanente Success Story haben mit der Kurs geht die ganze Zeit nach oben, sondern teilweise viele natürlich auch ins Bodenlose und insgesamt ist diese ganze Geschichte noch äh sehr volatil.
Da werden wir auch noch viel drüber reden, was das eigentlich alles so für Auswirkungen hat.
Ja und ähm wir haben uns gefragt, ob wir's erleben werden, dass wir mit Bitcoin beim Bäcker Brötchen kaufen können? Das,
bisher noch nicht stattgefunden.
Also man kann irgendwie VPN und äh Hoster könnte man damals bezahlen. Das geht wahrscheinlich jetzt auch immer noch, aber es ist irgendwie aus diesen Nerdkreisen nie so richtig herausgekommen und Tesla hat mal irgendwie fürn paar Minuten lang Bitcoin als Bezahlung,
aber ich glaube, das haben sie dann auch schnell wieder sein lassen.
Äh ich glaube eine ganz spannende Änderung äh die da passiert ist, die wir damals vielleicht gar nicht so vorhergesehen haben, ist, dass es auch völlig aus der Mode gekommen ist mit Bitcoin direkt zu zahlen, weil die Transaktionskosten einfach mittlerweile viel zu hoch sind.
Also das was man heutzutage tut ist, man hat ein Konto bei irgendeiner Webseite, die die Bitcoins für einen verwaltet.
Äh transferiert dann von da Kleinbeträge und eine echte Bitcoin-Transaktion macht man eigentlich nur, wenn man irgendwie ab vierstellig,
übertragen möchte. Also das äh Bitcoin mit Bitcoin beim Bäcker bezahlen wird auch nicht mehr passieren.
Genau, also es soll das ist das ist, sagen wir mal so etwas, was sich eigentlich äh bisher nicht anders entwickelt hat, sondern es ist halt eigentlich dann doch mehr so eine Art.
Aktienmarkt geworden. Es ist äh nach wie vor etwas, worin man rein investiert und sein Geld reinsteckt, schlichten in der äh mit der Erwartung,
dass es sich irgendwie lohnt. Ja, also so wie man sich Aktien von Apple kauft, weil man denkt so, die steigen schon irgendwie. So steigen die Leute in Bitcoin ein.
Weil man ja auch überall ähm erzählt bekommt, was das doch für eine tolle Sache ist.
Ja also das äh dürfte ja keinem entgangen sein, dass äh dass alles total durch die Decke ging und damit meine ich eigentlich mehr so die öffentliche Debatte.
Technisch hat sich eigentlich seitdem nicht so viel getan. Aber man muss auch sagen.
Frage, wird es security mäßig halten? Ist die schon beantwortet?
Da hat sich eigentlich auch nicht viel geändert. Also was sich technisch getan hat, muss man vielleicht unterscheiden bei Bitcoin ist nicht viel passiert, aber natürlich gibt es viele andere Entwicklungen, die äh wir sicherlich beleuchten müssen. Ähm,
mit mit Everidium, mit mit anderen Chains. Ähm Bitcoin selbst hat sich äh tatsächlich nicht viel bewegt.
Es gab natürlich schon ein paar Änderungen. Also es es gab ja verschiedene
Protokollanpassungen, ähm verschiedene Aufteilungen auch, mit so Aus- äh Gründungen wie Bitcoin, Cash und äh ähnlichen Sachen, also das so wirklich aus der,
Bitcoin ähm Geschichte, also diese Blockchain ist ja sozusagen so eine,
Eine ewige Hysterie von Transaktionen, ja und es gibt im Prinzip genau diese eine Linie, der alle vertrauen, weil das ist die, auf die man sich geeinigt hat. Aber man hat sich halt in der Zwischenzeit auch mal irgendwo getrennt, das heißt, es sind komplette Bäume
worden und haben dann sozusagen als eigene Währung weitergelebt. Weil in irgendeiner Form dort eine andere Philosophie verfolgt werden sollte. Die vielen sinnvoll erschienen, aber vielleicht eben nicht,
allen. Am Ende ist aber im Bitcoin selbst immer eigentlich als die das dominante
Kryptogeld in dieser ganzen Szene geblieben, so nach wie vor so die Leitwährung in gewisser Hinsicht, an dem irgendwie alles hängt und ich glaube, das ist auch denn.
Grund, warum es überhaupt,
da ist, weil äh so fangen alle noch nicht bereit sind diesen Glauben ziehen zu lassen in der Erwartung, dass dort immer noch mehr Geld für die Leute, die schon investiert haben,
geboren werden kann, beziehungsweise, dass alle, die jetzt noch einsteigen, auch äh selber davon profitieren können, ne, also eigentlich ist es ja so eine Art Pyramidenschema.
Geworden. Äh das alle einzahlen.
Ich finde äh also diese Bitcoin-Cash-Abspaltung äh ist ein relativ interessanter Punkt, weil es zeigt eine Sache, äh die sich auch so ein bisschen wie ein roter Faden durchzieht, wenn man sich mal anguckt, was noch passiert ist und äh welche Probleme so aufgetreten sind.
Das ist nämlich diese äh dieses Ideal, das dahinter steht, diese Philosophie von es ist alles dezentral,
ja niemand kontrolliert das, dass es gar nicht stimmt, sondern es gibt schon Punkte, wo ähm eine sehr sehr kleine Anzahl von Leuten dann doch äh die Finger drauf hat und die Kontrolle drüber hat
und äh das geht äh zum Beispiel damit los ähm festzulegen, wer baut eigentlich die Software, wer definiert das Protokoll,
definiert die Änderung diesen Protokoll. Also im Prinzip,
äh diese völlige Dezentralität, die gibt's auch bei Bitcoin nicht und die gibt's auch in den anderen Systemen nicht. Da sind immer irgendwelche zentralen kleinen.
Gruppen von Leuten oder sogar Einzelpersonen, die am Ende dann doch Entscheidungen treffen.
Mhm. Ja. Gucken wir doch mal, was sich konkret technisch getan hat. Also,
alle Protokolländerungen, wie ich das so wahrgenommen habe, hatten eigentlich immer
das Ziel so bestimmte Schwerfälligkeiten im System äh aufzulösen und so
Größenordnung in Griff zu bekommen, die anfangs optimistisch auf einen bestimmten Wert gesetzt wurden und sich später als,
erwiesen haben. Was war denn das?
Genau, also da gab es äh zum Beispiel Diskussionen über die Einzeltransaktionen, die äh in einen Block reinpassen. Ähm.
Prinzip aber nichts, was äh,
zu grundlegenden Änderungen der Philosophie geführt hätte, ne? Also Bitcoin ist heute ähm größtenteils dasselbe, wie es vor vor elf Jahren war als für die andere Sendung gemacht haben.
Mhm. Aber so Probleme wie,
dass es lange dauert eine Transaktion bestätigt zu bekommen. Es gab ja vor ein paar Jahren gab's da mal so eine Krise wo,
Transaktionskosten enorm in die Höhe stiegen, ja. Das ist ja auch so ein Detail, sollte man vielleicht noch mal kurz äh erläutern. Also das Geld für die Teilnehmer in dem Netzwerk, die es technisch dort mitmachen.
Also die quasi an diesem Kryptographischen Proof of Work Prozess teilnehmen, die wenden ja,
Strom, Aufwandzeit, Computer äh auf, um eben immer wieder diese.
Heschwerte zu äh rechnen, die so eine bestimmte Eigenschaft haben
um damit eben die Transaktionen bestätigen zu können und um dafür entlohnt zu werden, gibt's halt zwei Dinge. Einerseits bekommt man immer noch
Bitcoin quasi von dem Netz geschenkt. Die werden dann neu geschaffen in dem Moment wo man eine solche Transaktion dann unterschreibt und die allgemein anerkannt wird.
Der Betrag ist so immer weiter runtergegangen. Ich glaube zum Zeitpunkt der Sendung kriegte man fünfzig Bitcoin.
Ja, so war das.
Äh hast du eine Ahnung, wie viel das jetzt derzeit ist?
6,25 sind's gerade.
Okay, das geht immer weiter runter, denn die Zahl von Bitcoin ist ja begrenzt und bei 21 Millionen ist dann irgendwie Schluss.
Und äh zusätzlich gibt's aber noch die Transaktionsgebühren, das heißt all die Leute, die in dem Moment, wo mit diesem gewonnenen Hesh-Wert
ähm der nächste Eintrag in der Blockchain gemacht wird
Dort werden ja dann eben die offen herumlungenen Transaktionen genommen und man kann selber ja in dem Moment, wo man überweist, sagen so, okay, ich bin bereit, folgende Betrag dafür zu bezahlen. Das ist so ein freiwilliger
Zahlbetrag, den man mit dem Auftrag mitgibt und wo man im Prinzip rät, was denn so als akzeptabel,
gilt und es einem durchaus ja auch passieren kann, weil man sagt so, nö, ich zahle nicht. Äh dass dann einfach niemand diese Transaktion aufnimmt, so nach dem Motto, ja, was hier kostenlos irgendwie.
Brauchst mir so nicht zu kommen. Habe das auch mal ausprobiert irgendwann mal und tatsächlich. Also dann hängt dann so eine Transaktion rum und wird dann halt einfach nicht bedient.
Da muss man dann nachträglich diese Transaktionsgebühr äh hochsetzen
damit es dann irgendwann äh abgeräumt wird. Aber es dauert dann halt einfach auch sehr lang und es gab irgendwann mal, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, auf welche Beträge die hochgegangen sind, aber die Transaktionskosten waren zwischenzeitlich mal extrem hoch.
Hm. Ja also wir hatten im April 2162 Dollar pro Transaktion. Das war so ein.
April einundzwanzig. Ach so, okay. Na ich hatte jetzt noch etwas, was noch ein bisschen länger her ist in Erinnerung, aber das ist letztes Jahr auch so teuer war, ist mir unklar und hast du eine Ahnung, was da die Ursache dafür ist?
Nee, das weiß ich nicht. 2018 hatten wir schon mal so einen Peak. Ähm das Feld.
Aber zusammen, jetzt wo ich's mir angucke, fällt das zusammen mit den entsprechenden Peaks der Kurse. Also vielleicht das einfach damit zu tun
also wenn der Markt angeheizt ist, alle kaufen, ja, alle verkaufen wie verrückt, der Preis geht hoch, ähm das sind auch viele Transaktionen passieren, dass dadurch natürlich die Transaktionskosten steigen.
Mhm. Weil ja die Zahl der Transaktionen auch begrenzt ist, die mit einem Block bestätigt werden kann.
Genau richtig. Also es gibt äh ja immer noch diesen einen Block alle zehn Minuten und eine begrenzte Blockgröße und mehr geht dann halt nicht rein.
Was ist da mit denen? Also wenn es denen jetzt durchgehend mehr Transaktionswünsche gibt als eigentlich in diesen zehn Minuten bestätigt werden können, was ist dann?
Na ja, die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes regelt das und dann steigt der Transaktionspreis.
Okay, also das ist dann sozusagen wirklich so ein so ein so ein Durchlauferhitzer an der Stelle und dann wird's halt auch einfach teuer. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man vielleicht wirklich mal schnell handeln wollen würde, dann wird's teuer.
Das kann passieren, ja. Ja. Es ist tatsächlich bei äh zu Ibuierungen kommen ja später noch. Ähm da ist es teilweise noch krasser, ne? Das äh da gibt's dann,
Daraus, äh ich ich greife ein bisschen vor, aber da kann's passieren, dass man sozusagen, ja, man kriegt Geld in den Topf, äh der Deal kommt nicht zustande, man bekommt sein Geld zurück.
Und am Endeffekt hat man vielleicht ein paar hundert Dollar reingetan und es kommt einfach nichts zurück, weil die Transaktionskosten zwischendrin zu hoch sind und alles Geld verbraucht ist.
Aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei bei Bitcoin. Eine eine zweite Sache, die dann später äh ins Feld geführt wurde, war dieses Lightning-Netzwerk mit dem Versprechen hier Transaktionen zu beschleunigen beziehungsweise auch äh günstiger zu machen.
Ich habe nie so richtig verstanden
was da eigentlich jetzt wirklich noch für eine Infrastruktur dazugekommen ist, weil das ist ja im Prinzip nochmal eine zusätzliche Infrastruktur jenseits der Blockchain.
Was ist das genau?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Overlay-Netzwerk, wo einfach kleinere Blöcke berechnet werden, die äh mit einer größeren Geschwindigkeit abgewickelt werden. Ne, also statt statt Zehn-Minuten-Takt hat man eine viel, viel höhere Taktung.
Am Ende wird die Transaktion auch wieder in der Bitcoin Blockchain verankert.
Und heißt das, dass es sozusagen für sich dann auch nochmal eine eigene Blockchain ist, die ihm nach anderen Gesetzen äh läuft.
Das ja im Prinzip ja fast, das ist das hängt da ja mit dran,
Das ist äh so was wie ja ja, ich habe die Transaktion schon gesehen und ich habe sie auch gesehen und vermutlich hat das alles stattgefunden. Wir gehen davon aus, dass in der echten Blockchain landet. Also so muss man sich das ein bisschen vorstellen.
Klingt jetzt nicht, sondern nicht vertrauenswürdig.
Ja, das äh.
Ich meine, was kommen denn da für für für Methoden zum Einsatz?
Es greift vielleicht ein bisschen vor. Also auch da gibt's dann äh Smart Contracts drin. Da gibt es äh ja also weiß nicht, ob man da im Detail noch dazu was sagen kann oder sagen muss.
Mich würde schon mal interessieren, wie das jetzt eigentlich genau funktioniert. Also ich meine, das ist ja eine eine eine separate.
Infrastruktur, so von so und die hat ja dann im Prinzip erstmal dieselben Probleme wie die Blockchain auch, dass ihr erst mal keiner traut.
So und,
was macht diese separate äh Infrastruktur dann vertrauenswürdig und wie interagiert sie,
mit der eigentlichen Blockchain, wo es ja rein soll. Also wenn ich jetzt irgendwie Geld versende und dann mache ich das über dieses Lightning Network, was passiert denn dann überhaupt?
Im im Prinzip äh sorgt das äh dafür, dass ein Zahlungskanal zwischen äh zwei äh Teilnehmern aufgebaut wird.
Tatsächlich erschließt mir sich auch nicht, wo das Vertrauen daherkommen soll und am Ende des Tages war Bitcoin Lightning ja auch nicht besonders erfolgreich.
Du meinst, das ist eigentlich gar nicht wirklich in Benutzung.
Ähm.
Habe ich also ich ich seh's nicht so viel, aber ähm das äh heißt ja noch nichts bei modernen ähm Kryptowährungen. Da gibt's ja so viele.
Und zwischen wem wird jetzt dieser Kanal äh aufgemacht? Also wenn ich jetzt dir jetzt äh Geld schicken wollen würde über das Lightning, dann würde ich einen direkten Kanal zu dir eröffnen oder wie?
Ungefähr so. Also äh kennst du die Art und Weise, wie äh äh Bankengeld austauschen? Wie Überweisungen funktionieren?
Kannst du es mir gerne äh näherbringen, weil ich glaube nicht, dass ich die Details kenne.
Ähm das funktioniert über ein sogenanntes Settlement.
Das heißt, irgendwie äh Überweisung eins, Überweisung zwei, Überweisung drei, Überweisung vier, ne? Da kommen zwischen Banken ähm jeweils eine ganze Menge Überweisungen so übern Tag zusammen.
Und am Ende des Tages rechnen die all diese kleinen Überweisungen hin und her zusammen und sagen, na ja, pass mal auf, am Ende sind äh.
Ist Geld von A nach B geflossen, ja? Zum Beispiel von Bank A nach Bank B eine Million,
dann loggen die sich bei ihrer ähm Zentralbank äh bei ihrem Zentralbankkonto ein. Also die die Banken machen im Prinzip ein Onlinebanking bei der Zentralbank, so wie du als Nutzer.
Äh Online-Banking äh bei äh deiner Bank machst. Ja und dann überweist Bank A an Bank B äh im Onlinebanking der Zentralbank diese Millionen.
Sie rechnen sozusagen alle anstehenden Überweisungen zusammen und sagen, aha,
der Summe müsste letztlich netto dieser Betrag von dir zu mir gehen, weil du mir mehr schickst, als ich dir schicke. So und dann
das alles letzten Endes eine einzige Transaktion, die über die Zentralbank abgewickelt wird.
So funktioniert das. Also und das Settlement und im Prinzip funktioniert Lightning auch so, ne? Das äh das heißt, da gibt es Notes, die äh rechnen damit. Ja, da findet also nicht wirklich ein Mining,
eher eine Protokollierung und dann am Ende äh wird äh ein Settlement gemacht über eine Bitcoin-Transaktion. Und äh dadurch ist es halt wesentlich schneller.
Versteher. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich daran teilnehme, bin ich dann aber auch schon so ein so ein etwas ähm wie soll ich sagen?
So ein bisschen so ein elivierter Teilnehmer des Netzwerks, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass ich irgendwie viele Transaktionen habe.
So zu einem bestimmten anderen oder mehreren, bestimmten anderen, die auch vielleicht mehr Transaktionen haben und darüber sozusagen den Kleinkram abwickeln.
Und das dann letzten Endes in der Summe sich sozusagen darüber einig werden, so okay, ich vertraue dir, dass diese Transaktion schon irgendwie passen und umgekehrt, aber am Ende muss doch dann doch jeder,
einzelne Transaktionen in der Blockchain reingeschrieben werden oder ist das dann nicht so. Das heißt, dann wird da wirklich nur das Hin und Her zwischen diesen beiden Zahlungsteilnehmern äh.
Genau.
Was ja dann dann sozusagen auch noch mal alles etwas weiter anonymisiert.
Prinzip ja, außer dass man natürlich ins Lightning Network auch reingucken kann, weil man da die Transaktion.
Ja, okay. Aber du hast den Eindruck, das wird nicht so richtig angenommen, weil das eben noch mal spezielle Software äh verwendet und eigentlich auch nur dann wirklich einen Nutzen hat, wenn du eben mit bestimmten Gruppen häufiger Geld austauscht.
Genau. Also ich hab's äh in der Praxis noch nicht wirklich als Payment-Option irgendwo gesehen. Allerdings sind auch die Zeiten vorbei, äh in denen ich im äh äh im Darknet illegale Modiums gekauft.
Echt? Bewegst du dich jetzt nur noch im legalen Bereich, Andreas? Bin enttäuscht.
Das das würde ich so nicht sagen, aber zumindest öffentlich behaupte ich.
Okay ähm also wir halten mal fest.
Aus unserer Perspektive, es gab zwar technische Anpassung aber an sich hat sich ein Bitcoin als solchem wenig getan.
Genau, sondern die tatsächliche Innovation, über die wir hier wahrscheinlich reden müssen, weil ähm the big elephant in the Room. Ähm die passierte woanders.
Ja, aber lasst uns noch mal kurz noch zu den Problemen, die sich ja jetzt schon abzeichnen, ähm was sagen, weil wenn man sich mal
anschaut, okay, wer nutzt jetzt Bitcoin? Also eine Nutzerschaft habe ich halt schon genannt. Das sind einfach alle Glücksritter, die der Meinung sind, wenn sich wenn ich hier heute Bitcoin kaufe, dann
äh kann ich die morgen teurer verkaufen, weil andere wollen das ja auch und der Preis steigt und deswegen geht das alles und im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen,
Hat schon ganz gut funktioniert. Hätte ich jetzt vor 11 Jahren kurz nach der Sendung einfach mal tausend Euro in die Hand genommen und mir irgendwie fünfhundert Bitcoin gekauft so, dann äh müsste es nicht mehr Podcast ne,
einfach die ganze Zeit.
Wär's jetzt, Pfand ist ja der und wird es trotzdem Podcast, weil dich doch sonst.
Stimmt. Vielleicht bin ich auch das schon, ja und mach's trotzdem so weiter, um das äh abzulecken. Das wird man so nie rausfinden können.
Genau. Na ja, es ist äh ist aber nicht ganz so, dass es komplett Spekulation ist, was da,
Ähm also Währung setzt sich ja immer durch. Ähm wenn es einen realen Wert gibt und der ist bei Bitcoin auch relativ leicht zu benennen und zwar ist Bitcoin genau deswegen erfolgreich geworden. Ich hatte eben erwähnt, die ähm die Untergrundmärkt,
ne? Irgendwie ähm die Schwarzmärkte ähm der
Drogen im Internet, Handeln mit Drogen, Internet hat im Prinzip Bitcoin aufgebaut, dadurch dass da ein realer Wert geschaffen wurde, ne? Du konntest mit dem Bitcoin was anfangen, konntest du nicht per Post einen Gramm Koks nach Hause bestellen.
Äh das hat ausreichend Glauben an den Wert der Währung erzeugt, dass überhaupt erst die Möglichkeit war, äh einen Spekulationsmarkt dafür aufzubauen.
Wie man ja gesehen hat gibt's noch eine zweite aufsteigende äh Industrie, die sich sehr über die Dienstleistungen des Bitcoin-Netzwerks freut. Das ist
äh Erpressergemeinde im digitalen Bereich, also
die halt Sicherheitslücken auf Computern ausnutzt, sich in die Systeme einschleicht und dann alle Dateien verschlüsselt und dem Nutzer äh quasi so eine Rechnung aufmacht, so,
Ja, also ich habe ja den Key und wenn du den auch haben willst und deine Daten wieder haben willst, dann brauchst du ja hier nur Betrag in Bitcoin an diese anonyme Adresse.
Schicken, dann passt das schon, was wohl dann auch ganz gut funktioniert, weil die Leute daran Interesse daran haben, dass dieses Business-Modell auch weiterhin funktioniert. Und das hat natürlich enorm zugenommen. Was haben wir nicht alles gehört in den letzten Jahren von
runtergefahrenen Unternehmen, Krankenhäusern und was nicht alles, die äh sich halt einfach so durch irgendeines Sicherheitslücke, von denen es ja genug,
ähm entsprechende eingetreten haben, dann eben konkret diese und in den aller allermeisten Fällen ist es halt einfach
Geld, was dort eingefordert wird und nicht selten eben Bitcoin. Und das erscheint mir manchmal so ein bisschen,
fast auch schon der einzige Nutzen zu sein, wenn man jetzt mal von der von dem Spekulations-Nutzen dessen gesellschaftlicher Nutzen ja auch nochmal in Frage steht,
da zu sein scheint oder gibt's noch irgendeine Killer App die dir einfallen würde.
Ja, also ich denke, dass äh,
Ren sind wir auf jeden Fall schon ein sekundärer Anwendungsfall ist, ne? Es würde nicht funktionieren, wenn die Währung nicht auf irgendeine andere Art und Weise schon einen Wert gehabt hätte.
Generell äh natürlich alle Untergrundgeschäfte, ne? Drogen, Waffen, ähm bestimmte Daten von Pornografie, ähm was auch immer. Ähm.
Da das das hat den Markt im Prinzip gepusht und äh und geschaffen.
Und halt auch alle Transaktionen, bei denen man äh zumindest.
Pseudonym sein möchte oder die nachverfolgbarkeit erschweren. Das heißt Geldwäsche ist ein ganz großes Thema und das ist natürlich etwas, was auch explodiert ist. Also das Ganze auch ein Thema, was wir später in der Sendung noch kriegen wollten, aber ich saß schon mal das ganze NFT,
Business äh ist äh im Prinzip groß größtenteils eine Geldwäschegeschäft, weil man man kann die Herkunft von Geld verschleiern am Ende.
Ja. Hm. Aber jetzt so blühende Landschaften und positive Auswirkungen fällt dir jetzt kein Beispiel ein?
Na es gibt äh also wenn man mal rumhört, was die Befürworter des Kryptogeldes so an Erfolgsgeschichten erzählen,
Ähm dann dann gibt es so an zwei, drei Stellen äh Sachen wo man sagen könnte, naja da ist zumindest was dran. Ähm ja und das sind Fälle, in denen man sozusagen,
sich in einer staatlichen Ordnung befindet, die das mit dem Geld nicht so richtig im Griff hat und äh,
Zum Beispiel das das Währungssystem zusammengebrochen ist. Ähm oder man möchte gerne Zahlungen entgegennehmen und äh das Land in dem man wohnt,
hindert einen daran, das zu tun. Ja, also das ähm das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine eine philosophische Frage, wo wir auch bei der Frage gelandet sind, woher kommt denn überhaupt die Idee,
des dezentralen digitalen Geldes. Ähm die im Prinzip ja auch stark verwurzelt ist mit äh,
der Ablehnung der staatlichen Kontrolle über das Geld,
Ja? Also das äh die die Befürworter reden halt viel davon, naja das böse Zentralbankgeld, das ist ja bloß erfundenes Geld und stellt keinen tatsächlichen Wert dar und so weiter und so fort.
Und äh die äh die Denkrichtung, aus der das kommt, ja, das ist im Prinzip äh eine libertäre Denkrichtung bis äh anarchokapitalistisch,
und leider auch sehr rechtsoffen hin dann zu Verschwörungstheorien über das äh Hochfinanzweltjudentum und so weiter und so fort. Also da wird's schnell sehr sehr gruselig, wenn man sich mal anguckt
ähm was die Deutsche dafür Dinge erzählen.
Mhm. Also es ist auf jeden Fall relativ früh klar geworden, dass in dieser ganzen politischen Debatte, in Anführungsstrichen, politischen Debatte um um Bitcoin, also immer die Frage mit wofür ist das gut?
Sich doch sehr viel.
So libertäres Gedankentum äh tummelt. So nach dem Motto der Staat hat mir ja nicht einzureden, mein Geld ist ja mein Geld.
Und ähm das wird auch irgendwie nicht nicht weniger so.
Aber jetzt sind wir dann doch schon wieder so in dieser politischen äh Bewertung. Wir können ja mal jetzt äh vielleicht erstmal so den Punkt Bitcoin an der Stelle mal äh abschließen, aber,
aus unserer Perspektive, wir sind uns dann glaube ich auch ein bisschen einig, ist es so, okay, Bitcoin läuft jetzt seit zwölf Jahren oder wie lange läuft das jetzt so ungefähr?
Das zweitausendacht, zweitausendneun rum ging's los, ne.
Okay sind schon.
3zehn Jahre, okay, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall äh hat es eine Dekade technisch überlebt. Das heißt, das System als solches hat zumindest erstmal gezeigt, dass es funktioniert.
Aber es hat auf dem Weg dahin relativ wenig Nutzen,
generiert, wo man sagen würde, der ist jetzt auch unproblematisch.
Das ist sehr vorsichtig ausgedrückt.
Es ist auch bewusst äh vorsichtig ausgedruckt, so. Es hat äh durch marginale Protokolländerungen so seine, seine, seine kritischsten, technischen Probleme soweit umschifft bekommen.
Aber äh es zeichnet sich auch irgendwie noch nicht ab wie so Kernprobleme wie der Energieverbrauch irgendwie in in Griff,
äh kommen soll und wir hatten den Energieverbrauch äh in der letzten Sendung auch schon mal angesprochen. Da meintest du, na ja Bitcoin irgendwie äh,
für eine Schnapsidee, das wird sich ja nie durchsetzen
das jetzt irgendwie alle machen, dann wird ja immer mehr Energie verbraucht, weil das ist ja quasi das Ding mit dem Proof of Work. In dem Moment, wo man an diesem System teilnehmen möchte, beziehungsweise wo man dazu beitragen möchte oder davon eben auch,
profitieren möchte, dass das System läuft, muss man einfach Maschinen betreiben und man muss sie quasi immer,
an der maximalen Grenze des technischen möglichen betreiben, weil das ist letzten Endes das, was es sicher macht. Man kann nicht mal so,
nebenbei aufm iPhone neun Hashblock berechnen und dann macht man halt irgendwie die Blockchain weiter, sondern es muss eben prinzipbedingt eigentlich immer das Maximum, was derzeit möglich ist und was das ganze Netz,
insgesamt bereitstellt machen und das Interesse daran Geld zu verdienen.
Und damit an diesem Bitcoin Mining Network teilzunehmen.
Das ist halt groß, weil das halt einfach so eine Goldgräber-Stimmung ausgelöst hat und es glühen die Maschinen überall, die Grafikkarten
vor sich hin. In China haben wir irgendwie äh nicht nur in China, aber vor allem in China äh äh gab's dann wirklich die absurdesten,
Orte komplette Fabrikhallen, die einfach nur vollstanden mit Computer-Hardware, die nichts anderes gemacht haben als Bitcoin-Berechnungen durchzuführen und natürlich dabei auch einfach enorme Mengen an Strom verbraucht haben.
Mhm.
Also finde ich äh im Nachhinein auch spannend. Äh also einerseits äh war ich offensichtlich weitsichtig genug zu sehen, dass äh das mit dem Stromverbrauch ein Riesenproblem ist
andererseits nicht äh weitsichtig genug, um zu sehen, dass der geilste Menschen so groß ist tatsächlich den Planeten dafür anzuzünden, ne.
Genau und das ist so ein bisschen die Situation, vor der wir stehen und das halt im äh Hinblick äh Klimawandel. Klar, wenn man jetzt so in die Bitcoin ähm.
Familie äh reinfragt, das Thema ist ja in dem Sinne überhaupt nicht neu und schon oft diskutiert worden. Kommen halt schnell so Argumente wie, na ja, äh durch
Coin wird ja nie Energienachfrage gesteigert und das äh fördert ja im Prinzip äh nachhaltige Energiequellen, weil die bräuchte man ja dann.
Was natürlich völliger Blödsinn ist, weil man könnte die nachhaltigen Energiequellen dann nutzen und die nicht so nachhaltigen abschalten, wenn wir Bitcoin nicht hätten, ne.
Ja äh genau so und äh es gibt jetzt die verschiedensten Einschätzungen darüber, wie groß dieser Energiebedarf,
jetzt tatsächlich ist. Es gibt da ja nicht wirklich jetzt äh eine einfache Möglichkeit das nachzurechnen, aber man weiß halt in etwa welche Technik man derzeit einsetzen muss, um überhaupt so was zu machen, was die an Strom verbraucht,
lange die rechnen muss für so einen Block und,
Wenn man das alles nachrechnet und dann gibt's ja verschiedenste Gruppen, die das getan haben, kommt man halt schon mittlerweile bei dem Energieverbrauch eines kleineren Landes bei heraus.
Genau. Also von äh von der Universe of Cambridge gibt's zum Beispiel den Bitcoin ähm Electric Consultion Index, der mit dieser Methode arbeitet und ähm.
Die äh der derzeitige Stromverbrauch, also just, wo wir reden, wird geschätzt auf 14 Gigawatt,
und es liegt irgendwo also der die untere Grenze sind fünf und die obere 35. Das ist sozusagen der Bereich in dem die Schätzung sich bewegt.
Also.
Der Giga Gigawatt ist ja äh.
Zu jedem Zeitpunkt.
Erstmal eine Leistung äh so eine 100 Watt Lampe, hat 100 Watt und wenn du sie eine Stunde anmachst, dann hat sie 100 Wattstunden verbraucht. Ja also,
in einer in einer Stunde äh verbraucht äh das Bitcoin-Netzwerk 14 Gigawattstunden. Ja und im Jahr 124 Terradstunden.
Das ist schon so, dass ich allein vor ein paar Atomkraftwerken.
Genau. Wir können ja mal äh Atomkraftwerk gucken wir mal nach äh Leistung in Deutschland. Was haben wir denn da? Wie viel Stromp.
Wieder ein paar abgeschaltet worden. Ich hoffe die Zahl stimmt.
Genau ähm wir sind bei 9 bis 13 Terabattstunden pro Atomkraftwerk.
Die Nullen in meinem Kopf richtig genau. Das heißt irgendwie wir sind bei 100 Atomkraftwerken Stromverbrauch. Also ein ein Reaktor pro Atomkraftwerk, der kann natürlich mehrere Blicke haben.
Okay.
Stimmen die Zahlen, stimmen die Zahlen im Kopfrechnen ist immer schwierig.
Also ich habe äh jetzt nicht so hohe Zahlen im äh in Erinnerung,
aber es sind schon mehrere Atomkraftwerke, die im Prinzip betrieben werden müssten oder halt auch irgendwelche anderen Kraftwerke.
Wir wir sind bei eins bis 1 ,5 äh Gigawatt Portomkraftwerk, das heißt wir sind bei zehn Atomkraftwerken für Bitcoin.
Derzeit genau. Ja das ist so und die Größenordnung, die ich auch im Kopf habe und das steigt natürlich auch permanent an.
Das kommt auch wenn man im Kopf rechnet, da verliert man mal eine null. Ja.
Ähm so und ich meine das ist vor allem real,
Also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so eine theoretische Berechnung, sondern der Strom wird verbraucht und der Strom wird
äh muss irgendwie erzeugt werden, damit der verbraucht werden kann. Und selbst wenn es solche Systeme gibt wie es gab ja eine Weile lang so schlicht vernetzte Wasserkraftwerke in China. Das ist so eine Erzählung,
Ja, wo dann halt Strom quasi erzeugt wird in zu manchen Momenten, deren nicht abgenommen wird.
Weil er nicht ins Netz gespeist werden kann, weil es dieses Energienetz an den Stellen nicht gab und,
einerseits entwickelt sich das natürlich auch in China so weiter, dass die ganzen äh äh Netze dann auch ähm entstehen und existieren, aber auch,
In dem Fall ist ja der Strombedarf ähm
real und man kann jetzt nicht unbedingt davon ausgehen, dass überall, wo jetzt so eine Grafikkarte vor sich hinglüht, um Bitcoins zu erzeugen, dann halt irgendwie so ein äh rumeilendes
Wasserkraftwerk in der Nähe ist, sondern es wird halt überall gemeint.
Genau, genau. Also es ist ein bisschen absurd zu glauben, dass da äh,
man den Strom nicht auch anders sinnvoll verwenden könnte, ja? Die äh in Island haben sie eine relativ gute Lösung dafür gefunden. Die haben ja sehr viel Geothermie und dadurch eigentlich mehr Energie als sie brauchen,
und äh die haben einfach ein großes Aluminiumwerk hingestellt. Da wird also äh ein substanzieller Anteil der Energie, die in Island erzeugt wird, geothermisch einfach in Aluminium verwandelt.
Bei Aluminiumherstellung halt generell wie Metallerstellung, nur so generell einfach extrem energieintensiv.
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr energieintensiv. Das Bauxid möchte den Sauerstoff nicht so gerne abgeben.
Und das ist eine sinnvolle Anwendung von von von solchen Energiequellen. Sicherlich steht ja auch das ein oder andere Miningrig äh in in Island rum. Aber das ist ja nicht der Punkt, sondern der Punkt ist halt einfach, dass die Gesamtsumme allein nur um eine einzige.
Kryptowährung.
Aufrechtzuerhalten. Wir reden ja jetzt ausschließlich nur über Bitcoin und es gibt ja mittlerweile hunderte von verschiedenen Kryptocurrencys, die versuchen bei diesem Spiel mitzumachen.
Alle sind irgendwie mit dabei und ähm
Ja, diese Energie wird halt real verbraucht und steht entsprechend anderen Nutzungen so nicht zur Verfügung beziehungsweise da wo eben eine Unterversorgung ist, müssen eben neue Kraftwerke überhaupt erst errichtet werden. Allein um diesen Bedarf zu decken.
Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, na ja Gott zehn Atomkraftwerke äh auf der ganzen Welt. Das passt ja schon. Tritt sich fest irgendwie, die Welt ist groß.
Aber.
Bleibt ja nicht dabei. Also das steigt ja jetzt weiter äh an dieser Energieverbrauch wird tendenziell immer höher, weil ja die Computertechnik auch in dem Sinne gar nicht jetzt so mithalten kann. Also die wird ja nicht immer energiesparender dabei. Richtig?
Genau, ist richtig. Also ganz im Gegenteil, sondern die vor allem der Energie wird eigentlich davon aufgesaugt, ja, wenn man irgendwie es schafft es effizienter zu machen, dann wird halt das Pashing schwieriger, weil die Leute eher schnell erhaschen können und dann sind wir wieder beim selben Energieverbrauch.
Ähm.
Es gibt jetzt äh natürlich Ansätze äh dadran was zu ändern. Ja also Bitcoin haben wir gelernt äh Proof of Work äh bei vielen anderen Coins äh wird über Proof of Steak geredet. Ähm.
Also Diverse, die die den Einsatz seit längerem verfolgen, also Jota war eine der ersten,
die äh seit zweitausend7zehn verspricht ja demnächst machen wir das alles ohne den Energieverbrauch und trotzdem dezentral,
Ähm eine andere Währung über die wir noch ausführlich reden müssen. Ähm will auf Proof of Steak oben äh umsteigen, Readle Soon now,
ähm und auch diverse andere, ne? Was was ist der Unterschied äh zwischen und
Ähm die Idee bei Proof of Steak ist, dass man nachweist, dass man eine bestimmte Menge der Währung besitzt und dann wird man halt im Losverfahren bestimmt als derjenige, der jetzt den nächsten Block berechnen darf.
Zumindest in der Theorie. Ähm,
Wenn das wirklich funktionieren würde, würde es äh ja einen sehr sehr wichtigen Punkt, der gegen diese äh Blockchain-Währung spricht, beseitigen.
Ich sehe leider das Problem, dass ich's noch nicht wirklich habe, funktionieren sehen. Also, wie gesagt, Iota verspricht es seit langem. Es gibt trotzdem immer noch,
den zentralen Knoten der am Ende beschließt, was jetzt die Wahrheit ist oder nicht. Ähm wenn man sich den aktuellen Text von Iserium durchliest, die aktuelle FAQ zu Proof of Steak, ähm.
Da werden also wirklich komplexe Angriffsszenarien geprüft und Mittel dagegen entwickelt und dann wird Geld auf der hinterlegt, dass dann später wieder ausgezahlt wird im Trade of C und da
aber am Ende des Textes äh steht dann so Punkten. Das heißt das ist dann aber doch wieder so äh zentrale Institutionen gibt, die sozial kontrollieren, dass
die richtige Chain die Richtige ist und die Antwort ist so was wie er ja so ist das dann halt. Ja ähm also es.
Hat dann doch wieder die Zentralbank sozusagen.
Manchmal hat doch wieder die Zentralbank, ja. Also vielleicht ist es ja auch die Lösung, dass wir dann doch wieder Zentralbanken einführen und jeder macht einfach seine eigene Zentralbank. Wer weiß, ähm.
Vielleicht sollten wir die Gelegenheit nutzen und mal das Fass aufmachen, so was was gab's denn an technischen Entwicklungen außerhalb von ähm Bitcoin?
Genau, weil vor 11 Jahren hat wir gesprochen haben, war Bitcoin quasi so das einzige Kryptogeld.
Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob zu dem Zeitpunkt, als wir die Sendung gemacht haben, nicht schon irgendein anderer Falg schon existiert hat, aber so,
ganz realistisch war eigentlich nur nur Bitcoin da. Und äh seitdem haben sich sehr viele,
Währungen entwickelt, ein paar haben schon angesprochen, wie Bitcoin Cash, die im Prinzip die selbe Technologie sind, die also exakt dieselbe Software, vielleicht mit ein bisschen anderen
Parametern verwenden, äh irgendwann sich quasi gefalkt haben, also quasi eine Kopie der Blockchain,
genommen haben und gesagt haben, ist okay, äh wir biegen jetzt hier ab. Ja, wir haben jetzt hier unsere eigene Wahrheitsfindung auf dem äh auf der selben Technologie und sind sozusagen so eine so eine so eine zweite Realität innerhalb der selben
Technikwelt, so. Äh dann gab's sehr viele andere Kopien, die sich gar nicht auf die Blockchain,
der äh von Bitcoin bezogen haben, sondern im Prinzip eine neue angefangen haben, aber technisch letztlich auch das Gleiche äh äh Sinn.
Durchscrollen und äh all diese ganzen Sachen und äh mittlerweile ist es ja auch schon so, dass es irgendwie immer so eine
ja eine Währung, äh gibt, die irgendjemand auf den Markt raushaut und mit irgendwelchen Heilsversprechungen, wo äh dann,
am Anfang ja so äh Coin-Releases äh gemacht werden. Ja also man gründet so diese,
Währung für partnert sich mit irgendwelchen,
Leuten, die viel Geld haben, die dann so Geld reinstecken und quasi somit äh Initialen Coins ähm versorgt werden, also indische, wie heißt das IC,
ICO, also inditional Coin offerings.
Dann sozusagen sofort von Anfang an so also eine Scheinnachfrage erzeugt wird. Leute kaufen sich dann irgendwie diese Währung, weil sie denken, da kommt da was bei raus. Dann steigt dann auch dieser Preis innerhalb kürzester Zeit.
So
Halt die eiligen Investoren am Anfang dann schon eben mit diesen Gewinn der ersten Welle schon wieder ausgestiegen sind und ihren Gewinn schon äh gemacht haben und der Rest äh verbringt dann eben Zeit in diesem kleinen neuen Pyramiden äh Schema,
so dass da die Preise eben nur so lange steigen wie noch Leute gefunden werden können, die daran glauben, dass das jetzt eben die tolle neue Währung ist, die wieder diese sagenumwobenen Gewinnsteigerung mit sich bringt,
bis halt dann die Nachfrage äh vereppt
weil die Leute merken, dass es halt einfach irgendwie ja gar nicht so viel Raum gibt für so viele verschiedene Währungen. Ja und es dann äh auch schnell wieder haben sie einlassen und da sind glaube ich
auch viele Gelder äh verbrannt worden von von Leuten und sicherlich haben die ein oder anderen Glücksretter auch eine ganze Menge Kohle dabei verdient. Aber,
abgesehen von diesen einfachen Bitcoin-artigen Kryptowährungen gab's dann vor allem mit einen neuen,
Ansatz, der andere technische Prinzipien verfolgt hat, was du die Gestaltung der Blockchain betrifft, aber noch sehr viel wichtiger. Mehr als nur dieses ich verwalte den Kontostand-Ding.
Mit eingebracht hat. Wie kam es dazu?
Das ging eigentlich damit los, dass Leute entdeckt haben, dass man ja beliebige Sachen ähm in die Blockchain schreiben kann, ja. Das muss nicht unbedingt eine Transaktion, ich weiß äh überweise Geld von A nach B,
sein, sondern das kann auch irgendwie äh ich grüße meine Oma und meine ganze Familie sein und das steht dann da einfach drin.
Und äh bekommt durch die Blockchain äh einerseits so eine Art Zeitstempel, ne, weil zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt, das da drin stand,
äh andererseits dadurch, dass diese Blockchain ja auf alle Rechner kopiert wird, ähm wird auch eine dezentrale Kopie davon abgelegt. Ja und ähm.
Hat eine ganze Reihe von Ideen getriggert, was man denn mit dieser Blockchain alles sonst noch machen könnte. Und der Hype
der hält ja ungebrochen bis heute an bis zu einer Bundesregierung, die ähm den äh den Führerschein in der Blockchain ablegen möchte, aus was für Gründen auch immer.
Zeugnisse, ja,
bizarr, bizarr. Aber war insofern ein Meilenstein, als das Iberium äh sogenannte Smart Contracts.
Eingeführt hat und die Idee war folgenden, ja, wenn man beliebige Sachen in diese Blockchain legen kann, dann kann man ja auch Code in diese Blockchain legen.
Ja und dann kann dieser Code ja auch mit anderen Objekten, die in der Blockchain liegen, interagieren, so was wie mit dem Geld, das da rumliegt ähm oder oder anderem Code.
Und äh das hat also äh für dafür gesorgt, dass ihre Regierung in kürzester Zeit sehr populär geworden ist und dass äh Leute ähm wie die Wilden angefangen haben äh,
Anwendungen für diese neue Technologie zu suchen, ne. Wir haben eine Lösung, was ist denn hier ein Problem, ähm das wollen wir bearbeiten könnten. Ähm.
Nach wie vor äh bis äh bis Stand heute ein Proof of Work. Das heißt, das Energieverbrauchsproblem fällt nicht weg.
Aber äh damit sind äh bestimmte spannende äh.
Geschäftsmodelle, sage ich mal, möglich geworden. Ja, zum Beispiel sowas wie man zahlt halt auf ein bestimmtes Konto ein, sein sein Ibrisium ähm,
solche Daos, das sind dann äh
Dinge, die da attraktiv geworden sind. Und wenn genug Geld zusammengekommen ist, dann sorgt der Code dafür, dass dann das das mit dem Geld was passiert und wenn's nicht zustande kommt, dann wird das Geld rücküberwiesen. Solche Geschichten kann man damit programmieren, ja, also dass man äh,
Art Vertrag äh in in Kot umsetzt.
Also mit Smart Contract ist im Prinzip gemeint, man hat,
sind im Programmiersprache, die auf der Blockchain abgelegt wird, das heißt in dem Moment, wo man diesen Vertrag formuliert, ist das quasi so eine Art, ich sage mal, so ein so ein automatisiertes Skript,
was,
auf dieser Blockchain abgelegt wird, was bestimmte Eingangssignale verarbeiten kann, ja? Bestimmte Bedingungen sind erfüllt oder sind nicht erfüllt und die dann eben Dinge auslösen.
Dann halt in der Regel irgendwie mit Geldzahlungen zu tun haben. Verstehe ich das so äh richtig?
Ungefähr, ungefähr, so kann man sich das vorstellen,
Klingt natürlich erstmal wahnsinnig spannend und äh alle Technokraten sind davon begeistert und bis man zu den Problemchen kommt, über die vorher keiner nachgedacht hat. Wer mal programmiert hat, weiß, äh wer Programmcode schreibt.
Bugs in seinem Programm drin und äh wie fixt man Bugs in einem Vertrag, der auf der Blockchain liegt, gar nicht, der ist ja unveränderbar.
So oops.
Wie Leute machen Fehler. Ist ja ist was ganz Neues.
Ja. Ja also das ist äh so ein ein riesiges Problem, dass dieses ganze Konstrukt hat und auch wer irgendwie in seinem Leben schon mal einen.
Nennenswerten echten Vertrag abgeschlossen hat und beim Notar saß und sich eine Stunde lang das hat vorlesen lassen.
Ja, der weiß, am Ende gibt's immer noch die salvatorische Klausel, wo dann drinsteht, ach übrigens und wenn wir hier irgendwas gebaut haben, was nicht geht,
so ein Vertrag ist ja im Prinzip auch Programmcode und auch da hat man Bugs drin. Ähm also wenn da was drinsteht, was so nicht geht, dann meinen wir das, was wir gemeint haben.
Und dann kann man zu einem Richter gehen und kann das irgendwie mit dem Richter ausdiskutieren, was man wohl gemeint haben könnte und was denn jetzt eine salomonische Lösung dafür ist. Und diese ganzen Kontrollmechanismen
die existieren da nicht, die fallen da weg. Im Übrigen auch ein Problem, dass man bei bei Bitcoin hat, ja? Wenn ich eine Kreditkartenzahlung mache und äh,
Ich kriege die Ware nicht geschickt, dann gehe ich zu meiner Bank und sage, diese Kreditkartentransaktion bitte rückgängig machen und dann,
muss sich der Händler drum kümmern, dass er seinen Vertrag mit dem Payment-Dienstleister behält. Wenn ich eine Bitcoin-Transaktion mache und werde beschissen, kriege ich mein Geld nicht zurück. Ja? Ähm.
Und auch diese äh diese ganzen Investment-Steams, äh die bei mit den Smart Contracts äh.
Gebaut werden. Ähm alle anderen Dinge, die sich so ausgedacht werden, die haben genau dasselbe Problem. Also es ist äh,
die äh es ist eine Technik. Technik macht A oder B.
Und wenn das falsch ist, fehlt das soziale Kollektiv, das rückgängig zu machen. Also diese gesamten Mechanismen, die wir zum Beispiel im Finanzwesen haben,
die dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Betrügereien nicht funktionieren.
Ja also so Berichtspflichten bei Aktiengesellschaften ähm Einlagensicherungsfonds damit Banken nicht pleite gehen ähm Prüfpflichten,
durch äh Wirtschaftsprüfer, die zertifiziert und unabhängig sind. Ja, das das existiert ja alles aus einem Grund und das existiert aus dem Grund, dass es historische Erfahrungen,
äh mit Bankensystemen Geldsystemen gibt, in denen das alles nicht vorhanden war und äh.
Dieses Fass machen wir halt gerade mit dem Digitalvirus, insbesondere mit den Smart Contracts.
Frisch auf. Ne, so das ist irgendwie wir setzen alles zurück auf Raubtier, Finanzkapitalismus aus dem 19. Jahrhundert.
Mit kalter Nerdlogik sozusagen.
Genau, genau, genau. Der der Glauben daran, der Code wird es schon richten.
Ähm was kannst du vielleicht mal so ein Beispiel nennen, was so ein Smart
contract so ganz konkret vielleicht auch schon mal geleistet hat. Also was ist denn so das das das Hello World äh
bei diesem Smart Contracts, wo man sagen würde so ach ja, also in diesem einfachen Fall ist das ja eine sehr praktische äh Sache. Das müsste man unbedingt mal zum,
Einsatz bringen und gucken, was damit ist.
Also.
Das was gerne gemacht wird ist sozusagen ähm äh unabhängige Teilwährungen rauszugeben, die auf Evarium basieren, ja, dass man keine Ahnung man macht sich seine Metaebene,
Man führt aber keine eigene Infrastruktur für Mining und so weiter und so fort ein, sondern die Mieterebene Coins werden über äh einen Smart Contract rausgegeben. Es ist ist es sinnvoll oder nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Vieles von dem, was äh man so sieht, wo gesagt wird, dafür könnte man das verwenden,
das löst sich bei näherer Betrachtung eigentlich immer in Wohlgefallen auf. Also ich habe neulich mit einem Künstler diskutiert, der meinte irgendwie, ja GEMA ist so scheiße, stimme ich natürlich völlig zu. Ähm wäre es nicht toll, wenn ich als Künstler meine Tantiemen über einen Smart Confect,
ausbezahlt bekomme.
Ich so, na ja klar, aber wie stellst du denn das vor? Na ja, wenn's zum Beispiel in der Türkei jemanden im Lied im Radio spielt, dann bekomme ich über den Smart Contract Geld ausgezahlt.
Fragst du ja wie stellst du dir das denn technisch vor?
Ja na weiß auch nicht so genau ne und dann ähm wenn man dann näher bohrt ist die Vorstellung offensichtlich, dass in der Radiostation, in der ähm MP3 Player Software
eine Logik eingebaut ist, die dann halt eine eine Transaktion auslöst. Also das äh da fehlt bei vielen Leuten offensichtlich das Verständnis.
Dass äh da ja kein Automatismus ist, der den Input in so einem Skript auf der Blockchain bedient, sondern da muss irgendwie immer noch dieser Input muss geliefert werden
und da geht die Betrügerei los. Ja, also ähm rechnet man MP3-Player das ab, wenn ein Lied gespielt wird oder nicht. Das kann's ja nicht kontrollieren und das da bringt so eine Blockchain auch keine Sicherheit.
Und rechnet ja auch das Richtige ab. Also behauptet er nicht einfach nur irgendein Lied zu erkennen und am Ende ist es dann doch immer wieder Helene Fischer.
Genau, genau, genau, genau, genau. So und äh aber wenn du soweit bist, ja, dass du sagst, na ja, ich habe vielleicht eine Zertifizierte Infrastruktur mit MP3-Playern, das wird auch staatlich geprüft. Warum macht der nicht einfach eine Überweisung? Ja, warum muss das irgendwie,
mit komplexen Smart Contract,
lalala passieren, wenn irgendwie eine eine SEPA-Überweisung automatisch ausgeführt, genau denselben Zweck erfüllt, nämlich ohne Mittelsmann das Geld zu transport.
Ja. Das ist natürlich hier so ein so ein so ein so ein so ein klassische Nerd Fall ähm das.
Oft der Reiz einer Technologie dazu führt, dass man sagt, oh das gefällt mir aber jetzt so gut und das hat irgendwie eine gewisse äh Eleganz und so so einen gewissen Neuigkeits äh Wert.
Jetzt möchte ich gerne unbedingt Probleme äh erdenken, wo das die Lösung für sein könnte. Und dann,
wird das sozusagen immer wieder ausm Schrank äh geholt und sagt so, aber da haben wir doch hier diese geile neue Technologie. Könnte das nicht irgendwie passen? Und,
diese Blockchain scheint ja jetzt in diesem ganzen Halbgebäude, was sich so in den letzten Jahren aufgebaut hat, äh ist es ja
Du hast es schon angesprochen ja bis in die Politik vorgedrungen, ne? Wir haben sogar im Koalitionsvertrag auch in dem aktuellen steht wieder drin, so ja wir müssen ja hier irgendwie Technologie fördern und dann so irgendwie irgendwas mit Blockchain.
Wenn man das schon mal so ankündigt, dann muss ja auch irgendwas passieren und dann kommen halt irgendwie äh Firmen an und sagen so, ja hier alles mit äh äh mit Blockchain und keiner versteht überhaupt noch
worum's geht. Dann haben wir halt so absurde Sachen wie unsere komischen,
Corona äh Zertifikate liegen dann auch noch in irgendeiner Blockchain rum oder wie schon erwähnt hier
welche Berliner äh Schulzeugnisse von Kindern werden in irgendeiner Blockchain abgelegt, wo man halt nur sagen kann.
Warum? Wozu? Was wozu braucht man? Äh äh das weil offensichtlich man überhaupt gar nicht mehr sagt,
Hier ist das Problem, was wäre die beste Lösung dafür, ja, sondern man geht halt mehr so hin und sagt so, ja, wir haben hier eine super Lösung. Jetzt brauchen wir halt noch das passende Problem.
So und äh weil das ist ja jetzt finanziert, jetzt müssen wir das auch für irgendwas zur Anwendung bringen. Na ja, dann hat man sich halt irgendwie ein teures Auto äh gekauft und bei einem nichts Besseres einfällt, fährt man halt äh immer 50 Meter bis zum nächsten Bäcker.
Äh hin und zurück, wo man halt auch hätte mal locker zu Fuß laufen können.
Mhm. So äh so ist das. Also,
viele Eigenschaften dieser Blockchain sind ja mehr oder weniger ein Abfallprodukt ähm von äh der Erreichung des eigentlichen Zieles. Ja also man hat äh zum Beispiel den Umstand, dass man einen Zeitstempel,
Service hat, ja? Also man kann's nachweisen, dass ein bestimmter Hash-Wert zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt bekannt war, indem man ihn einfach in die Blockchain reinschreibt.
Ähm was man aber viel einfacher haben könnte, wenn zum Beispiel die äh äh sagen wir die Bundesdruckerei einen digitalen Zeitstempelservice betreibt.
Kann, kann ja durchaus auch 'nen Merkfitrieh sein, das heißt 'ne Verkettung von damit man zeigen kann, dass die Heschwerte alle stimmen, das nicht manipulierbar ist und so weiter und so fort. Aber.
Merkel-Trie, das müsste mal kurz äh.
Merkelbaum. Ähm das äh.
Im im Prinzip äh der kryptographische Ansatz, der wesentlich älter ist als eine Blockchain. Eine Blockchain kann man als Spezialfall eines Merkel bei uns betrachten, ne. Ähm Hesses sind ja äh,
etwas, was sicherlich die meisten Leute mittlerweile verstanden haben, ne. Man nimmt nimmt einen großen Haufen Bites.
Stopft in eine Funktion rein, die da einen String einer festen Länge draus macht,
mit der Eigenschaft, dass äh das ein relativ schwer zu fälschender Fingerabdruck der Daten ist, die da oben reingekommen sind,
Ähm was ist ein Merkelbaum? Ein Merkelbaum ist jetzt wenn man sagte man hat Datenblock eins, da habe ich jetzt ein Hash von Datenblock zwei habe ich ein Hesh von. Da kann ich von dem Hashtag von Datenblock eins und dem Hashtag von Datenblock zwei,
ja und dann habe ich drei und vier,
deren Hashtag kann ich jeweils wieder zusammenfassen. Jetzt kann ich den zusammengefassten von eins und zwei einen zusammengefassten Hashtag von drei und vier wieder einen Hash bilden.
Und äh.
Das baut so eine Art Baum auf, wo in die Knoten des Baumes zum Tischwerte und ganz unten in dem Baum hängen die eigentlichen Daten drin, ähm die man bearbeiten will. Sagen wir bei einem Zeitstempelservice jeweils die Sachen, die notariell beglaubigt werden sollen, die da reinkommen.
Und äh warum macht man das? Das macht man aus dem Grund, dass man, wenn man überprüfen will, ob der stimmt,
nicht immer alle durch alle Daten durchgehen muss, die jeweils an diesem Service vorbeigekommen sind, sondern man kann gucken, wo ist man in dem Baum, ja? Und dann berechnet man nur für den einen Datenblock, für den interessiert, ob der gültig ist, den Hash.
Und da kann man sich den Baum hoch hangeln, da jeweils die Herschwerte nehmen und wenn man oben wieder rauskommt beim richtigen Wert, weiß man, dass auch der eine Datenblock äh korrekt gerechnet wurde, ohne dass man alle anderen angucken muss,
und ist im Prinzip.
Einen Sonderfall davon, wo man das also nicht in der Baumstruktur zusammenfasst, sondern bloß den rechten Rand eines Baumes hat, ne? Man macht also einen Heschwert von den aktuellen Daten.
Von dem Blog davor. Dadurch bildet sich die Blockchain,
kann man prima verwenden, auch für so einen digitalen Zeitstempelservice. Was fällt dabei weg? Was man nicht braucht, ist die dezentrale Datenbank und was man auch nicht braucht, ist der dezentrale Konsensalmrhythmus. Also was die,
ähm,
Bitcoin ja äh erfunden wurde und was das Besondere ausmacht. Ist die Kombination dieser drei Aspekte. Man hat äh verteilte Daten, jeder hat eine Kopie aller Daten,
Man hat äh eine eine Verkettung der Heshes davon, die dafür sorgt, dass man sozusagen nicht Sachen reinschmuggeln kann und man hat äh eine äh dezentrale Konsensfindung über diesen Proof-Off-Effekt Algorithmus und äh,
was im Prinzip drei verschiedene Technologien sind, die miteinander kombiniert werden und deren Kombination halt den speziellen Mehrwert erfüllt. Damit kann ich Drogen im Internet kaufen.
Ja und äh jetzt gibt es viele Probleme, wo man so was braucht wie eine dezentrale verteilte Datenbank,
oder man braucht äh eine Verkettung von Heschwerten, um Fälschungen in der Vergangenheit zu verhindern,
oder man braucht einen eine dezentrale Konsensfindung.
Aber was halt sehr populär ist, ist Probleme zu nehmen, die bloß ein oder zwei dieser Technologien brauchen und sagen, ja dann nehmen wir Blockchain, weil das kann das alles,
Unter nicht-Berücksichtigung der Tatsache, dass äh diese verteilte Datenbank-Blockchain die schlechtest mögliche verteilte Datenbank ist, die man sich vorstellen kann, weil nämlich alle eine Kopie von allem haben.
Und äh man zum Beispiel größere Datenmengen gar nicht in der Blockchain ablegen kann, sondern immer nur Hashes von Daten.
Zeit Stempelservice hatte ich erwähnt, äh das Problem lässt sich anders lösen und äh also viele Anwendungen ähm ja die äh lassen sich mit anderen Technologien einfacher lösen und diese Fragen muss man stellen.
Wenn man sich anguckt, äh was wird denn immer gesagt, was äh so prototypische Probleme, äh die die Blockchain lösen sollen? Ist zum Beispiel,
Rückverfolgbarkeit von Rohstoffen.
Und da sind wir wieder bei genau denselben Problemen. Ja, wozu brauche ich die zentrale Konsensfindung? Ist völlig überflüssig. Ähm wozu muss ich eine Kopie von allem überall speichern? Ist völlig überflüssig. Eigentlich brauche ich bloß die Verkettung von Heschwerten.
Natürlich reicht es auch nicht aus, weil wenn ich am Anfang reinschreibe, ja also dieser Sarg Kaffee, der wurde hier gerade organisch erzeugt,
Stimmt es denn? Ja, das kann mir die Blockchain auch nicht sicherstellen. Also dieses dieses Märchen von wir können das Lieferkettenproblem mit der Blockchain lösen. Das stimmt einfach auch hinten und vorne nicht. Und ähnliches gilt für im Prinzip.
Also ausnahmslos alle Anwendungen, die äh für die die Blockchain verwendet wird und vorgeschlagen wird bis hin zur schon besprochenen ID.
Ja. Ja zumal ja auch dieses Problem, dieser Konsensfindung und äh ist bisher sozusagen überhaupt keine,
andere zuverlässige Methode gefunden wurde als Proof of Work.
Und Proof of Work bedeutet, es gibt ein großes Interesse daran, von vielen Leuten,
diese Information sicher zu halten, da sich sozusagen einig zu werden und das funktioniert bei Bitcoin, deshalb, weil,
so viel Geld dahinter steckt und weil potenziell damit Geld zu verdienen ist. Aber mit der Herkunftsliste von Kaffeebohnen,
halt in dem Sinne überhaupt gar kein Geld zu verdienen. Also warum sollte irgendjemand einen Computer irgendwo hinstellen und äh berechnen lassen? Ähm ja um das aufrechtzuerhalten, wenn da auch vor allem sonst nicht
viel äh drin passiert.
Und in dem Moment, wo es wirklich ein solches Interesse gibt, sind wahrscheinlich alle anderen so plegmatisch äh unterwegs, dass es auch überhaupt gar kein Problem ist, diese Blockchain dann mal eben auch komplett zu übernehmen.
Also,
Ich schüttel auch regelmäßig immer wieder äh äh mit dem Kopf. Ich meine äh man muss vielleicht die die Industrie äh in Deutschland die Softwareindustrie dahingehend so ein bisschen äh in Schutz nehmen, weil äh.
Ich meine, da kommt dann halt die Politik und sagt so, na ja, wir fördern hier irgendwas und werfen da viel Geld rein. Natürlich erzeugt das einen
gewisses Interesse und natürlich äh versucht man dann nützliche Technologien, die vielleicht irgendwie so dargestellt werden äh können, dass es jetzt zu dieser Förderungsbeschreibung passt, da irgendwie mit
in den Topf reinzuwerfen. Insofern ist äh ist äh einfach schon mal das falsche Lockmittel äh unterwegs und man muss sich dann eben auch nicht wundern, wenn das dann äh auch ausgenutzt wird. Es ist halt bloß dann immer total dramatisch.
Dann eben auch so Bereiche, äh,
betrifft, wie zum Beispiel eben die Schule, die Bildung ähm ja oder die Bekämpfung äh einer Pandemie, wo wir einfach äh uns relativ wenig
sinnlose äh Aktivität leisten können, um uns einfach auf das wirklich wichtige
konzentrieren zu können, dass dass dann halt äh mit solchen Sachen dann auch noch in Verbindung gebracht wird. Das ist äh wirklich beunruhigend.
NFTs sollten hast du ja schon mal angesprochen, ne, also die Tokens. Das ist auch äh so eine Sache. Das müssen wir mal erläutern.
Genau. Also Funghi sind ja Pilze. Es handelt sich also um Geld, das nicht schimmelt.
Nee, kleiner Witz.
Ähm was was meint das? Ähm äh das ist im Prinzip der Unterschied zwischen äh einer Münze und einer Banknote. Ja zwei Münzen,
kannst du nicht unterscheiden,
äh also schon, wenn du einen Kratzer reinmachst, aber im Grunde genommen weißt du nicht, wenn du eine Münze auf dem Tisch hast, was hat die für eine Geschichte? Die sind austauschbar, ne und dieses Functional heißt eigentlich austauschbar. Du kannst dir eine Münze nehmen, die andere Münze nehmen, ist genau dasselbe. Auf einer Banknote,
steht eine Seriennummer drauf. Die ist also nicht austauschbar. Ähm.
Hat zwar auch dieselbe Zahlungsfunktion, ne, aber du kannst sie voneinander unterscheiden. Und äh jetzt sind also Leute auf die Idee gekommen, ja, wenn man diese non-funcial Tokens hat, äh also sozusagen etwas, wo eine Seriennummer dransteht,
dann könnte man ja da auch ähm.
Besitz dran schreiben, also das sozusagen verwenden dafür äh etwas anderes als Geld zu repräsentieren. Ja und ähm derzeit sehr populär sind äh Bilder von Affen.
Es ist ich ich ich wünsch's ich wünschte es wäre ein Witz. Es wenn man das erzählt, das klingt immer alles so absurd, ja. Ähm die äh.
Die Idee war mal ähm wir hatten's ja irgendwie bei äh bei Bitcoin sind Leute auf die Idee gekommen, ne? Man kann ja beliebige Sachen reinschreiben und dann taucht da also Aski-Art in der Blockchain auf,
und irgendwann saß also mal jemand da und hat in einem Hackathon gesagt, na ja, was ist denn, wenn wir jetzt komplette Kunstwerke in die Blockchain reintun? Hat ein bisschen mit rumgespielt und hat festgestellt, dass leider die ähm
Blockgrößen sind begrenzt und so weiter und so fort. Man kann es nicht wirklich machen, aber ich mache hier mal so ein Proof of Concept, der eine URL eines Bildes in die Blockchain reintut,
Ja und ein ein Eigentümer dranschreibt, ja das äh Verknüpfung existiert zwischen einem bestimmten Bitcoin.
Konto oder was auch immer es für eine Währung ist, also ein ein Konto, was ja einem private Key entspricht,
ist der Eigentümer eines bestimmten Betthaufens und das repräsentiert äh tatsächlich echtes Eigentum an zum Beispiel einem digitalen Gut.
Wobei es genau genommen nur das Eigentum an einer URL ist.
Ja es ist nicht mal Eigentum, weil dazu müsste ja irgendwie ein Vertrag zustande gekommen sein. Das fehlt an an dem fehlt es ja auch. Also äh ist sozusagen ein ein Datenblock, in dem eine URL drinsteht.
Auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise mir gehört, äh aber halt eigentlich nicht das Kunstwerk, was dahinter ist, weil die die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen dafür fehlen.
Aber ich könnte jetzt sozusagen so ein Affenbild äh nehmen, so Metaebene, Monkey und du denkst dir so geil.
Das brauche ich. Ich will jetzt der alleinige Besitzer dieses Kunstwerks sein und möchte dem Künstler, Tim Brid Love, auch was Gutes zukommen lassen und dann äh möchtest du es gerne kaufen. Dann sage ich ja okay, gib mal Bitcoin und dafür
dann aber das findet jetzt auf der statt oder wo ne? Genau und ähm,
dann lege ich dort irgendwie eine URL hin, wo draufsteht, irgendwie Metaebene, ME, Meta Monkey Punkt äh JPEG.
Ja und.
Kriege ich Geld von dir.
Im Prinzip ja und dann kann's äh kann es weiterverkauft werden an den nächsten und so weiter und so fort
Und aber das das hat natürlich alles vorne und hinten Haken. Also irgendwie das äh dass da ja gar kein Vertrag zustande gekommen ist. Äh damit geht es los, ne. Also eigentlich bräuchte es
ähm ein äh ein ein äh rechtliches Rahmenwerk außenrum, das tatsächlich äh die äh die Nutzungsrechte und das Eigentum an den Nutzungsrechten regelt.
Das fehlt einfach, ja? Das ist ist gar nicht da.
Und das Zweite ist ähm die die Leute, die dann also einen technischen Details nicht so tief drin stecken und irgendwie ihr neugewundenes Geld für äh irgendwelche Affen ausgeben.
Völlig entsetzt, wenn andere Leute äh in der Lage sind per äh rechter Mausklick.
Ähm so was gibt's bei Mac bestimmt auch. Ähm Simulation einer rechten Maustaste.
Heißt das.
Ja das äh das Bild einfach runterladen können. Sagen wie wie geht denn das? Das gehört doch mir. Ja, ist doch oft der Blockchain verankert, ne? So funktioniert das nicht. Ja. Ähm.
Dass da nur eine URL drinsteht und das was hinter der URL legt sich ja jederzeit ändern kann, verstehen die Leute auch nicht. Also das ist auch wieder ein äh,
Prinzip ein Versprechen, dass da gegeben wird, nämlich dir gehört etwas, dadurch, dass es auf der Blockchain passiert, was also von von vorn bis hinten nicht stimmt, was irgendwie äh technisch so nicht funktioniert, was rechtlich so nicht funktioniert.
Äh das das zweite Riesenproblem ist, dass da auch ein unfassbarer Spekulationsmarkt entstanden ist mit äh mit diesen NFTs.
Einfach weil keinerlei Transparenz darüber herrscht äh was mit diesen Bildern passiert. Ja was mache ich als Künstler, ne? Ich mache so eine Kollektion NFT ist.
Gebe die raus,
dann borge ich mir von irgendjemanden eine Million in dann kaufe ich diese Bilder von mir selbst für keine Ahnung hunderttausend das Stück, die zehn Bilder jeweils.
Und plötzlich ist ein riesen Markt dafür entstanden,
Sagst, oh so super collection und guck dir an, wie die im Wert gestiegen ist und dann findet sich natürlich irgendein Dummer, der sich denkt, oha, pass mal auf Schnäppchen, kostet bloß achtzig, das kaufe ich jetzt mal.
Und äh plötzlich ist aus dem Nichts ein ein Wert entstanden, Leute bewerfen nicht mit Geld, ne, ich gebe meine geborgte Million zurück und habe hunderttausend verdient.
Ja also.
T ist wirklich quasi so Berliner Luft. Ja, also man man füllt einfach Luft in Flaschen und sagt so, hier kost was.
Und diese URLs, die da rausgegeben werden, das ist ja auch teilweise so absurd, also viele von denen, die da schon verkauft wurden,
Gibt's dann auch gar nicht mehr die URLs. So, sind irgendwie schlecht gewartete äh Server, irgendwelche NFT-Archive.
Wo dann halt einfach auch noch noch noch nicht mal der ohnehin Sinnlose Content, der dann äh hinter dieser URL versprochen wurde äh in irgendeiner Form auch real überhaupt noch klickbar ist, ne.
Wahrscheinlich gibt's das Bild irgendwo noch das geht immer noch rum. Und diese ganze Idee dahinter ist halt quasi so einen virtuellen Besitzmarkt zu
zu bauen, der in irgendeiner Form
von diesem Kunstmarkt inspiriert ist. Ja, der letzten Endes auch mit solchen Wertsteigerungshof verbunden ist, ohne dass man jetzt mehr tun muss als so ein Objekt irgendwie so,
halbwegs in Shape zu halten, also so ein Bild. Ja, das musste immer noch ordentlich lagern und das muss dann irgendwie beim Verkauf auch irgendwie dem Besitzer äh real, physisch äh wechseln und das
kannst du an eine Wand hängen und und und und stolz drauf sein, in diesen ganzen digitalen Gewese mit den NFTs, ist ja noch nicht mal das gewährleistet.
Also, dass das überhaupt die Daten noch existieren, weil sie sind ja nicht auf der Blockchain selber, sondern es ist dann nur eine Referenz, die unter Umständen gar nicht mehr existiert und äh man hat halt auch nicht diesen alleinigen Anspruch darauf.
Und damit ist es halt sozusagen noch noch weniger nichts und noch noch noch mehr Luft in der Flasche als äh mit anderen Systemen schon.
So ist das. Also das äh im Prinzip sind das äh moderne Äquivalente zu irgendwie einer Rolex im Arm oder mit einem Lambo vor der Tür vorfahren. Ja, es geht eigentlich also der eigentliche Wert ist äh
die zur Schaustellung sinnlosen Reichtums, der da betrieben wird.
Grad äh dieser dieser Board-App äh Jagdclub ist äh da da glaube ich das ausschlaggebende Beispiel, wo es äh auch auch gar nicht mehr um die Kunst an sich geht, ne. Es ist irgendwie furchtbar langweilige Variationen des immer selben Affen
Ähm den Künstler kennt auch niemand. Äh äh aber man hat's, kauft gleichzeitig eine Eintrittskarte in einen exklusiven Club in äh in Kalifornien.
Und äh man äh man muss halt irgendwie die dicke Goldkette auf seinem Brustfältchen raushängen lassen. Dafür ist es da.
Ja. Aber keine absurde Technologie wäre ja nicht so absurd, dass die FDP das nicht fordern würde.
Äh die haben's also tatsächlich geschafft in den Koalitionsvertrag äh die Idee des Blockchain basierten Grundbuchs reinzubringen. Ja also ja.
So also.
Wofür?
Digitalisierung first Bedenken second.
Ach so.
Es ist modern, hilft bestimmt irgendwie das zu machen. Ähm hat keiner verstanden warum. Ähm schaltet mal wieder völlig in der Realität natürlich, weil es äh insbesondere bei Grundbüchern bestimmte Einträge gibt, die gesperrt sind,
bekommst du nicht, ja? Also wenn du ein Grundbuchauszug äh ziehst, kann es sein, dass da Daten drin sind, die nicht veröffentlicht werden dürfen.
Und das kriegst du schon nicht mehr abgebildet. Also auch schon wieder so eine völlige Schnapsidee. Es es hilft niemandem was. Es bringt nichts. Ähm aber es klingt nach Blockchain, deswegen findet die FDP das gut.
Ja hm,
Haben wir ähm viel über Bitcoin schon geredet und auch über, was ja zumindest eben,
zumindest so das mit diesem Versprechen daher kamen andere Funktionalitäten zu haben, ne. Wir haben über die Smart
gesprochen. Du hast ja auch schon diese äh das Kürze Dow angesprochen. Das steht für Dezentralisierte, autonome Organisation. Ähm was letzten Endes glaube ich so ein bisschen
die Visionen,
versucht zu transportieren, das irgendwie ganze Unternehmen in irgendeiner Form, in dieser Blockchain äh agieren über Smart Contracts mit irgendwas äh verbunden sind und darüber irgendeinen Wert.
Darstellen. Ähm auch so etwas habe ich irgendwie in real noch nicht erlebt, dass das jetzt irgendein.
Bezug zur Realität hat, dass dass da dass da irgendetwas passiert, wo man sagt so, ah ja, das hat die Welt gebraucht. Oder? Gibt's da ein Beispiel, was man erwähnen könnte?
Gab's mal diesen Dow, der eine seltene Kopie der US-Verfassung kaufen wollte und gescheitert ist. Also nein.
Okay.
Jetzt gibt's ja auch noch andere Projekte, die zumindest teilweise versucht haben bestimmte Lösungen anzubieten, die jetzt die Kryptowährung an sich haben.
Also ähm Z-Cash ist glaube ich in dem Zusammenhang etwas, was man äh nennen muss, was was wurde denn da mit Neues eingebracht?
Also Z-Cash löst einen relativ spannendes Problem. Ähm.
Also spannend äh wir denken uns wieder rein, wir hatten's ja irgendwie, wenn ich also große Mengen Drogen international verschiebe, ist ähm Bitcoin ein sehr geeigneter Mechanismus für das ähm
sind wir wie beim Settlement, ne? Das funktioniert bei Drogendealern ja nicht anders als bei bei Banken. Irgendwann muss dann Geld verschoben werden.
Aber die Erpressung darfst du nicht vergessen. Die ist auch die steht auch im Flur.
Das das ist ja bloß Piggyback, aber tatsächlich haben und auch die dasselbe Problem, ne. Ähm,
Die äh ich ich habe also einen Haufen Geld und es ist klar, das kommt aus illegalen Machenschaften. Was mache ich denn jetzt damit? Und äh sowohl Bitcoin als auch Iverium haben ja im Prinzip das ewige Lockfall. Jede Transaktion wird aufgezeichnet.
Und es ist natürlich möglich mit äh entsprechender Datamining Technologie das Geld auch nachzuverfolgen.
Und ähm ja gibt's dann Ansätze, da Geldwäsche zu betreiben? Wir werfen alles in großen Topf und rühren um, holen's wieder raus, aber.
Am Ende des Tages ist es transparent, das Geld geflossen ist und auch wenn keine Namen an den Kunden stehen, man sieht von welchem Konto auf welches Konto ist Geld geflossen? Ähm Z-Cash führt jetzt ähm Zero Knowledge Proofs.
Ein. Das ist ein Seronolischproof, das also ein kryptografisches Verfahren ähm das äh wasche mich, aber mache mich nicht nass erlaubt
Das heißt, ich kann dir nachweisen, ähm dass ich eine Unterschrift habe unter meinem Scheck ohne dir die Unterschrift zu zeigen.
Ähm das kann man dann so zusammenstecken, dass also Geld überwiesen wird, so dass es bei dem, wo es ankommen soll, ankommt ohne dass die Welt hinterher in der Blockchain sieht, wo das Geld denn eigentlich hergekommen.
Und ähm das gibt's auch schon eine Weile und es erstaunt mich, dass es sich nicht stärker durchgesetzt hat,
offensichtlich sind die,
Geldwäscheaufklärungsbestrebungen noch nicht so gut, äh dass es zu einem ernsthaften Problem geworden ist bei den entsprechenden Leuten oder die Geldwäsche, Mechanismen koppeln halt an Real World Geldwäsche an und sind gut genug, um für die Leute, die viel Geld verschieben,
Abstimmung bereit zu halten. Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ist auf jeden Fall technologisch spannend an der Stelle und auch bei wird drüber diskutiert äh dass in der nächsten Version einzubauen, dass man auch da einen Siro-Nole-Spruch drin hat. Also da äh eine sehr sehr spannende Technologie.
Was würde denn das bedeuten? Also ich meine wird Set Cash denn jetzt schon genauso gehandelt wie äh die anderen Währungen auch.
Ja wird es und auch schon seit einer Weile, ähm aber längst nicht in den Voluminat, die ich erwarten würde. Also offensichtlich ist das Problem Geldwäsche,
also Geldwäscheverfolgung nicht so groß als das die Leute die das Problem haben in Scharen zu Z-Cash gewechselt werden.
Aber könnte sozusagen noch kommen.
Das könnte noch kommen und definitiv ist es auf der Roadmap von ähm von Iserium zum Beispiel. Genau wie Puff of Steak und ähm was nicht alles.
Es gibt ja noch so ein anderes Problem, was wir ja jetzt schon mehrfach äh immer wieder am Rande angesprochen haben. Das und der Aufwand für diese ganzen Transaktionen ja so groß ist. Und so eine
äh Versprechungen, die immer gemacht wurden, ist ja, dass diese ganze Kryptogeld sozusagen das das maschinelle Bezahlen in so einem IOT äh Kontext sozusagen, ja, Maschinen
äh überweisen sich gegenseitig Kleinstbeträge, Micro Payment für bestimmte Dienstleistungen, dass so äh etwas damit befördert wird. Da gab's doch auch ein paar Ansätze, die äh versucht haben, dass.
Zu machen. Was ist denn daraus geworden?
Also da wäre mir auch nichts bekannt. Was ist das grundlegende Problem gelöst hätte. Also das äh.
Aber aber angekündigt wurde es trotzdem. Es gab immer dieses Iota oder.
Na, Iota ist im Prinzip ein wahr, ein früher Versuch, äh äh Proof of Steak zu machen.
Da gibt es also dann äh sie redeten von dem ähm also statt einer Change gibt es einen und irgendwie kommt am Ende dann die Wahrheit raus und äh derzeit wird die Wahrheit noch bestimmt durch den zentralen Server, der sagt, was die Wahrheit ist in diesem,
ähm äh Jothe hat überhaupt mehrere technisch äh.
Fragwürdige Entscheidungen getroffen. Unter anderem arbeiten sie nicht mit äh Bits die zwei Zustände haben, sondern mit Herrn Niralogik mit drei Zuständen, weil sie die Vision hätten, dass man das ja mal in Hardware bauen kann, dann wird alles viel effizienter.
Sie haben sich eigene Hashfunktionen ausgedacht, die natürlich komplett um die Ohren geflogen sind, als man Kryptograf draufgeguckt hatten, musste sie doch wieder klassische Ash-Funktion nehmen.
Und die also da da gab's tatsächlich mal eine Ankündigung von Bosch, dass sie irgendwas mit Iota und IoT machen und dann ging's drum.
Keine Ahnung, so ein typisches irgendwie, na wir haben verkettete Hashes und da kann man ja Lokfalts reinwerfen, dann sieht man, ob Locks verloren gehen. Das war so ein bisschen die Überlegung an der Stelle und deswegen hatte das was mit IoT zu tun.
Aber auch das ist einfach komplett im Sande verlaufen wegen Sinnlosigkeit.
Ja. Also man kann zusammenfassen die reinen,
Kryptowährung,
die derzeit so im Umlauf sind, auch wenn sie unterschiedliche Ausprägungen, Details haben, äh kochen alle mehr oder weniger mit demselben Wasser.
So, sie haben auch alle mehr oder weniger dieselben Probleme. Manche haben so ein paar kleine Features, aber kein Feature hat jetzt wirklich dazu
geführt den Platzhirsch Bitcoin, der eigentlich am trägesten ist in irgendeiner Form nennenswert zu
Iteriaum macht zwar ungefähr so die Hälfte des Volumens von Bitcoin aus. Das ist von daher definitiv so der große Platz zwei, aber dahinter wird's dann auch schon dünner und der Rest schlägt sich sozusagen um das restliche Geld, was in dem Markt ist.
Dafür spricht, dass du eben die die technischen Eigenschaften derzeit eigentlich im Großen und Ganzen keine große Rolle spielen. Sondern das ist halt eigentlich das reine Investment selber ist und das,
Auch der Brand, der der sozusagen von so einer Währung verkörpert wird, eine sehr viel größere Rolle spielt,
Bitcoin haben, Bitcoin kaufen. Das ist halt irgendwie so ein so ein Wort, das das das ist halt auch schon äh zu
den normalen Bürgern, die sich eigentlich mit solchen Technologien und Investmentsystemen nicht groß auseinandersetzen in irgendeiner Form durchgedrungen und äh erweckt so eine Assoziation von
von Wert.
Ja ist so. Ich war neulich in Zürich und als man wenn man am Flughafen landet, wird man erstmal von großen Plakaten begrüßt, wo drin steht. Irgendwie investieren sie in Bitcoin über Name einer Schweizer Bank, ja. Äh ähm also ich würde mal sagen, es gibt.
Durchaus noch ernstzunehmende Anwendungen im Bereich äh.
Ja, das das äh euphemistisch ausgedrückt internationalen Geldverkehrs äh an äh den äh existierenden Kontrollen vorbei.
Äh der Rest ist ein Spekulationsmarkt und reiner Spekulationsmarkt.
Gut, dann lass uns mal so ein bisschen ähm,
anderen Bereich nochmal abklappern, weil was ist ja sozusagen jetzt auf jeden Fall ausgelöst hat ist dieses Bitcoin,
Mark zwar jetzt noch nicht so die finanziellen, voluminar aufgenommen haben, das wirklich in irgendeiner Form ein
Player ist, auch wenn's halt so ein Spekulationsblase ist, in der sich grade äh sehr viele herumtreiben.
Trotzdem steht ja die ganze Zeit immer wieder irgendwie im Raum, löst diese Technologie im Prinzip unseren,
Unsere Vorstellung der Repräsentation von Geld in elektronischer Form. Und das ist natürlich vor allem auch eine Frage
sich äh diejenigen, die derzeit das Geld eigentlich repräsentieren, also die Staaten und die Zentralbanken auch stellen müssen. Also gibt es irgendeinen inneren Wert in dieser Elektronifizierung von Geld.
Versus eines reinen benutzens der Netzwerke um Transaktionen im normalen Banksystem durch die Gegend zu schicken. Also hat
sozusagen eine, wie soll ich sagen, so so eine so eine digitale Fleischwerdung von Geld in irgendeiner Form ein,
Nutzen ist das ein Weg, den man gehen muss. Und damit verbunden natürlich auch die Frage, stellt dieses Kryptogeld in irgendeiner Form auch eine Bedrohung für die existierenden,
Geldsysteme dar. Es wird ja von den Supportern von äh Kryptowährungen ja auch
nicht selten genauso dargestellt, ja, dass das hier so wirklich ein Kampfinstrument ist und man würde sich halt irgendwie jetzt von den Zentralbanken befreien und von der Inflation et cetera
äh äh das ist ja äh schon teilweise auch eine relativ aggressive Formulierung, wie hier an die Sache rangegangen wird. Immer unter dieser Prämisse, dass sozusagen,
dass Zentralbankensystem an sich etwas Schlechtes wäre.
Also erstmal würde ich glaube ich sagen, das Geld ja heutzutage schon elektronisch ist. Ja, also man hat zwar noch Bargeld in der Hand, aber im Wesentlichen funktioniert ja das Bankensystem heute auch schon komplett elektronisch,
Ne, ich glaube, die letzte Bank, die äh Bücher auf Papier geführt hat, äh hat vor zwanzig Jahren dicht gemacht oder so was. Also das,
im Prinzip sind wir da schon und äh.
Die Frage ist halt nur, wer verwaltet die Kontostände?
Ja, ja, so die ähm wer verwaltet die Geldmenge? Ist äh vielleicht eine spannende Frage,
und was heißt denn zentrale Kontrolle über Geldmenge überhaupt? Und das ist äh am Ende natürlich eine sehr philosophische, die draus hinausläuft äh glaubt man daran, dass ein Staat eine gute Sache ist, ja oder nein.
Und äh die äh also diese Abschaffung von Zentralbankgeld, dadurch, dass man's ersetzt durch ein,
wie auch immer geartetes Geld, das halt nicht zentral verwaltet wird. Kommt aus der libertären Ecke und ist in der Konsequenz eigentlich eine eine anarchistische Forderung.
Allerdings auch eine Anarchokapitalistische Forderung. Sind ja irgendwie also den Anarchismus gibt's ja in verschiedensten Geschmacksrichtungen, da gibt's eine ganz hervorragende Copypasta von einem äh amerikanischen Anarchokapitalisten.
Der also äh Griechenland besucht und gehört hat, da gibt's eine anarchistische Szene,
und äh dann äh mit Leuten ins Gespräch kommt in einem Haus, in dem große anarchistische Logos hängen und am am Ende wird da dann verprügelt, weil sie rauskriegen, ne. Er ist halt ein Arche-Kapitalist. Was bedeutet denn das?
Und äh na ja das bedeutet irgendwie, ich habe meinen Besitz und du kannst sie mir nicht klauen, aha du bist also Faschist,
Ähm Anarchismus ist nicht gleich Anarchismus und wir sind hier in einer Strömung, die sozusagen sagt, wer wer Besitz hat, der darf das besitzen und Eigentum verpflichtet nicht. Das ist äh der Gedanke, der so ein bisschen dahinter steht.
Und ähm,
Was natürlich auch eingebettet ist in entsprechende ähm politische Strömung, die versuchen den Staat äh zu entmachten und die Institutionen Staat abzuschaffen,
im Prinzip ein äh ein eine Art Feuillerismus wieder einzuführen. Ja, wer wer besitzt hat recht.
Mhm. Und das gab's ja auch schon mal. Ich meine, das Geld basierte irgendwann mal auf Gold.
Und das war sozusagen das Regulativ und diese Zentralbanken konkret dann vor allem auch die amerikanische Zentralbank,
hat dann dieses System abgelöst und damit überhaupt erst mal Kontrolle über diese Geldmenge gehabt, weil die Geldmenge ja vorher einfach nur über das Gold definiert war und wer hat, der hat und wer nicht hat, hat halt nicht.
Genau, genau und äh dieser Glaube daran, dass irgendwie äh dieses äh Geld, das durch einen realen Wert äh repräsentiert wird, etwas Gutes ist,
der ist halt in diesen Kreisen relativ verbreitet es wird,
dem Gold irgendein intrinsischer Wert zugeordnen, was natürlich auch völliger Blödsinn ist. Warum ist Gold was wert? Ja, weiß ich nicht, wann man sich darauf geeinigt hat.
Weil's schön aussieht und ähm schwierig zu kriegen ist uns nicht so viel davon gibt.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich. Aber die Abschaffung der Goldbindung hat äh im Prinzip damit zu tun, äh mit der Erkenntnis, dass äh die Steuerung der Geldmenge,
volkswirtschaftlich durchaus sinnvoll sein kann und da gab's auch Beispiele, damals als wir noch goldgebundene Währung hatten, Gold- und Silbergebundene Währung aus der Vergangenheit.
Ähm als nämlich die Spanier irgendwann angefangen haben äh Südamerika äh zu kolonialisieren und auszuplündern.
Stieg auf einmal die Menge dessen Europa im Umlauf befindlichen Goldes und Silbers enorm an.
Und äh die Verfügbarkeit äh der der Währung des Geldes hat dafür gesorgt,
dass äh auch die Wirtschaft in Gang gekommen ist. Ja und das hat ja nichts mit der Wirtschaftsleistung zu tun. Die Leute haben ja nicht plötzlich doppelt so schnell gearbeitet, weil mehr Gold im Umlauf war, sondern einfach das Vorhandensein der Währung, das die die Erhöhung der vorhandenen Geldmenge,
hat dafür gesorgt, dass es einen wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung.
Die Einführung von Zentralbankgeld ist äh nichts anderes als diesen Mechanismus explizit zu machen und eine Zentralbank kann also über die Steuerung der Geldmenge.
'n Einfluss darauf haben wie es der Wirtschaft geht und durch geschickte Steuerung auch dafür sorgen den allgemeinen Wohlstand zu steigern. Also das ist der.
Der chinesianische Ansatz und ähm.
Jetzt auch gibt's die äh ganz modernen Depots, Kinesianisten, die Modern Monetary Theory, die sogar sagt, dass überhaupt gar keine Probleme in der Stadt so viel Geld druckt wie er möchte,
Das das das fördert die Wirtschaft am Ende des Tages sammelt ihr das Geld wieder ein über die Steuern ja ähm und äh.
Kann damit steuern, ja? Deswegen heißt es steuern, weil man damit politische Steuerungsprozesse betreiben kann und es ist auch gar nicht schlimm, dass der Staat halt Geld druckt, sondern das ist seine Aufgabe.
Und da da prallen halt komplett unterschiedliche Philosophien und politische,
Glaubenssysteme aufeinander an der Stelle.
Wir haben ja auch vorhin auch schon bemerkt, so in dem Moment, wo irgendwie die ganzen Zahlungsströme äh immer anonymer werden und nicht mehr nachvollziehbarer sind. Das ist natürlich auch äh der beste Weg, Steuern zu vermeiden.
Genau das äh also was ja ein Problem ist, dass das existierende Bankenwesen auch schon hat. Ja also viele große Vermögen,
sind schon dem Zugang entzogen und eine eine Anonymisierung und Digitalisierung des Geldes würde diesen Prozess natürlich noch äh beschleunigen.
Also auch an der Stelle muss man sich überlegen sind Steuern was gut ist, ja oder nein? Also ich finde es gibt bestimmte Aufgaben.
Kann ich eigentlich als Einzelner, als Individuum gar nicht leisten und äh die Vorstellungen dann legen wir halt zusammen und bauen eine Straße
ist auch ein bisschen utopisch. So was wie ein Gesundheitssystem äh sollte solidarisch aufgebaut werden. Also ich glaube schon, dass ein Staat äh eine bestimmte Funktion hat, die,
sehr sehr wichtig ist und das Überleben im allgemeinen befördert.
Ähm es gibt natürlich auch Bereiche, wo wo ich der Meinung bin, da hat der Staat vielleicht nicht so viel zu suchen. Also.
Ja also ein gewisser Freiheitsrahmen muss auch da sein.
Ist ein ist ein Zwiespalt, aber dieser Ansatz wir schaffen es komplett ab. Äh wir sorgen dafür, dass der Staat nicht mehr existiert, dass keine Steuern mehr erhoben werden. Den finde ich schon relativ gefährlich.
Tja, was machen wir denn jetzt sozusagen mit diesem Zauberlehrlings,
Moment, so kommt's mir so ein bisschen äh vor, ja. Also der Besen da ist äh sozusagen sehr aktiv äh geworden.
Und wir haben jetzt sozusagen dieses Versprechen.
Krypto Geld oder was heißt Versprechen, das ist gar nicht mal so ein Versprechen, es ist halt eigentlich mehr eine Technologie-Demonstration. Man hat halt gezeigt, aha, wenn's ums Geld geht,
eigentlich auch nur dann, dann ist man in der Lage, so eine dezentrale,
Infrastruktur hochzuziehen, die so ein Konsens darüber aufrechterhalten kann, wem gehört jetzt von diesem Kuchen wie viel?
Und was ist das wert.
Na wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal. Ja, also da gab's ja jetzt relativ populär den Fall von jemanden, dem über,
Wenn das stimmt, was er in seinem Tweet geschrieben hat, äh eine eine Backdoor auf einem Smart Dildo seine neuen äh Affen geklaut wurden im Millionenwert.
Und,
da da wo da wurde jetzt der Weiterverkauf äh dieser äh NFTs auf den entsprechenden Plattformen gesperrt und er schreibt nach der Polizei. Also das äh ja die äh,
das ist in sich widersprüchlich, weil das gar nicht so ist, dass es wirklich dezentral funktionieren kann, dass es ohne soziale Regeln funktionieren kann.
Mhm. Ja aber selbst wenn es äh technisch funktionieren würde mangelt es halt einfach an.
Konkreten Ergebnissen, wo man sagen würde, so, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Die einzige Auswirkung, die derzeit wirklich problemlos nachgewiesen werden kann, ist.
Einzelne verdienen damit eine ganze Menge Geld. Ja und der Großteil der überwiegende Teil des gesamten Bitcoin-Vermögens gehört sehr wenigen Leuten,
Denen, die am Anfang massenhaft Bitcoins,
erzeugt haben und dann halt so die zweite und dritte und vierte Generation von Glücksrittern, die dann früh mit größeren Mengen eingestiegen sind und irgendwann wird sich das System halt erschöpfen.
Weil es gibt in dem Sinne ja gar keinen Gegenwert. Außerdem, dass alle anderen auch noch daran glauben und deswegen ihr Geld da reinschmeißen.
Also eigentlich ist es wirklich das klassische äh äh Pyramidensystem.
Wo halt alle irgendwie ihre ihre Kohle reinschmeißen und diejenigen, die schon ihre Kohle drin haben, davon profitieren.
Aber an sich dem überhaupt gar kein realer Gegenwert äh entgegensteht. Also da ist ja sozusagen nichts, außer das System,
selbst, was dann halt auch noch nur, um es aufrecht zu erhalten, auch noch Unmengen an Energie verbraucht.
Gerade die äh der Energiekonsum macht eigentlich die Gesamtbewertung relativ einfach. Ja, wenn wenn das nicht wäre, wenn man sagen könnte, nee, wir haben ein funktionierendes Proof of Steak
stellt sich immer noch die Frage, ist etwas, was wir als Gesellschaft wollen? Es ist etwas, was philosophisch in Ordnung ist.
Und äh ja da ist die Antwort na vielleicht ein bisschen in gewissen Grenzen. Ähm.
Aber so mit Proof of Work kann man eigentlich bloß sagen, so schnell wie möglich verbieten.
Ja. Das wird ja teilweise auch schon getan. Es gibt ja jetzt auch äh
Gegenbewegung China scheint schon eine gewisse Haltung gegenüber der Kryptowährung gefunden zu haben. Da wurden in der letzten Zeit ja dieses Mining.
Doch weitgehend äh untersagt. Ich weiß nicht, wie erfolgreich das war.
Aber es war ja lange Zeit so, dass wirklich, glaube ich, über die Hälfte der der Bitcoin meiner Station irgendwie äh aus China zu kommen schienen.
Mittlerweile nicht mehr der Fall, ne? Und überhaupt ist halt die Frage.
Wer dominiert sozusagen die Zahlungswege im Netz? Das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen die eigentliche Frage, die dahinter äh steht. Also mal abgesehen jetzt von dem rein,
Spekulationstum, was konkret eben Bitcoin und äh den Verwandten mitgebracht haben, stellt sich ja auch immer noch so diese Frage, wie organisieren wir sozusagen den Geldflow? Und,
bisherige Bankensystem, wo halt einfach mal im Wesentlichen die Werte derzeit gehalten werden und den Großteil der Transaktionen nach wie vor durchgeführt wird und das wird wahrscheinlich auch noch lange Zeit so bleiben.
Bieten natürlich alle möglichen Schnittstellen an, um das eben, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, eigentlich so elektronisch, wie es eben derzeit geht, zu
zu machen, aber natürlich sind auch dort
sehr viele Gate-Keeper am Start, die sagen, na ja, hier darf soll aber nicht jeder mitspielen äh und wenn dann nur zu meinen Bedingungen und ähm die Bedingungen sind halt, ich will an allem irgendwie mitverdienen. Alle wollen sich überall in diesen Zahlungswege einklinken und irgendwie was
verdienen,
die Kreditkartenbetreiber wollen irgendwie für das Weiterreichen der Bezahlung über ihre Kartensysteme und ihre Netzwerke einen Anteil des.
Haben. Apple möchte gerne für äh die Security Dienstleistung, die ihr Apple Pay liefert, auch noch einen Anteil davon haben. Und die Banken wollen halt irgendwie natürlich auch mit Transaktionsgebühren
mitverdienen, alle wollen irgendwo,
mitverdienen. Ist ja auch klar. Haben ja auch teilweise äh Kosten soweit. Äh auch nix äh falsches, ob das dann irgendwie genug ist oder nicht. Muss man mal sehen. Trotzdem ist es natürlich ein ein asymmetrisches System und durch die
Dynamik des Netzes verschieben sich auf jeden Fall die Kräfte am laufenden Meter, werden nun in Zukunft
Player sind und wer nicht
Und zwischen diesem rein totalen hundert Prozent wir sind ganz woanders Kryptogeld. Ja was sagt wir brauchen
theoretisch keine Infrastruktur von euch, außer.
Eure Kraftwerke, die finden wir ganz geil und irgendwie das Internet ist irgendwie auch ganz praktisch. Das nehmen wir mal so mit, aber ansonsten sind wir die totale Freiheit.
Gibt's ja dann auch noch so Zwischenansätze. Es kam irgendwie letztes Jahr glaube ich äh war das Facebook mit dem Plan so ach ja äh wir haben hier auch eine ganz geile Währung Libra
ja
Würden wir doch ganz gerne mal in Facebook irgendwie äh alle Bezahlaktionen machen. Also wir würden gerne nicht, dass du mit Dollar bezahlt wird, sondern wir sollen dann einfach äh alle motivieren mit Libra zu bezahlen.
Und damit das sozusagen auch was wert ist,
und nicht so ein volatiles Ding ist wie Bitcoin und äh auch nicht so hohe Transaktionsgebühren macht. Äh binden wir das über irgendwelche Fonds an die Weltwährung an?
War nicht so,
Erfolgreich erstmal, weil glaube ich die Weltwährung gesagt haben so äh Moment, ihr wollt jetzt hier irgendwie den Zahlungsverkehr übernehmen, da haben wir aber was dagegen.
Na es ist äh.
Wenn man mal einen Schritt zurücktritt, ist äh jeder, der sozusagen äh für mich Geld bewegt, wo ich ein Konto habe, ja Account und Konto ist ja nicht äh.
Zufällig äh dasselbe Wort. Der ist eine Bank,
Ja und nur weil Facebook sich jetzt anders nennt, sind sie trotzdem eine Bank und jede Organisation, die für mich Geld verschiebt, ist im Prinzip eine Bank,
Und äh es ist nicht einzusehen, dass da äh,
Andere Regeln gelten sollten als für andere Banken. Also sicherlich hat das Bankensystem Probleme, an denen man arbeiten muss. Also grade die Kreditkartenzahlung, ne, mit der Monopolsituation, dass es dann im Prinzip zwei Unternehmen gibt, die dann auch noch US-Amerikanisch sind und dann ihre,
moralischen Standards anfangen ähm entsprechend durchzusetzen und ich darf dann plötzlich keine Nacktbilder von mir verkaufen, weil das ist ja unanständig und pfui und obwohl ich in einer Justizion bin, wo das völlig erlaubt ist, kann ich keine Kreditkarten dafür nehmen. Das ist ein Problem.
Da muss man dran arbeiten. Ähm aber am Ende des Tages.
Kann's nur lauten nach Reformierung des Banksystems, weil es bleibt hinterher immer noch eine Bank, was immer da rauskommt, wenn's nicht mein Geld ist, wenn's nicht bei mir liegt und es ist bei Bitcoin jetzt auch so, ist es eine Bank.
Trotzdem gibt's ja jetzt auf so verschiedene Projekte, die eben versuchen in irgendeiner Form sich noch so dazwischen
einzuigeln. Also Facebook ist mit seinem System erstmal soweit gescheitert, dass er es schon wieder erforderlich genannt haben äh erforderlich gefunden haben, das äh umzubenennen, das heißt jetzt glaube ich irgendwie ein DM das äh Projekt ist noch ein bisschen unklar wie
wie's da weiter äh gibt und es gibt ja auch so du hast vorhin schon dieses Tesa angesprochen, das äh,
ja auch so ein bisschen so äh eine Kopplung an das normale Währungssystem zu haben.
Äh ja genau und bei Täter mit dem spezifischen Problem, dass äh die Anzeichen, dass das Geld gar nicht wirklich da ist.
Doch relativ stark mieren, ne. Sie behaupten, sie haben eine 1 zueins Kopplung an den Dollar.
Und viel äh des Marktwertes von Kryptowährungen ähm basiert auch darauf, dass auf irgendwelchen Börsen ähm diese Kryptowährungen gegen Terror getauscht werden hin und zurück.
Äh es steht einfach im Raum, dass wenn alle Leute anfangen ihre sich auszahlen lassen zu wollen, dass die Firma sehr sehr schnell pleite ist und das Geld eigentlich gar nicht da ist.
Ist ein Problem, das natürlich Zentralbanken nicht haben. Also es gibt ja diverse Projekte, dass äh ja Banken, die Zentralbanken, ihre Zentralbankwährung auch als Egel rausgeben.
Was natürlich eine völlig andere Situation ist, ne. Die brauchen erstens keinen dezentralen äh Konsensalgorithmus, das heißt, die können auf das ganze Poof of Jörg verzichten. Ähm und.
Damit ist es am Ende des Tages im Prinzip dasselbe Geld, genau dasselbe Geld, was jetzt schon rausgeben nur in einer anderen Bittdarstellung. Und das ist also,
nicht mal in der selben Kategorie betrachten wie ein Bitcoin, weil's einfach technisch total anders funktioniert, nämlich mit einem zentralen Gletscher statt einem dezentralen.
Mhm. China macht das bereits.
Mexiko hat es glaube ich angekündigt so etwas einzuführen. In der EU wird es äh diskutiert sicherlich auch in den USA. Die Frage ist wie hast du dann äh hast du da eine Ahnung, wie das so technisch äh begonnen wird?
Habe ich mir nicht im Detail angeguckt, aber wenn ich mir angucke, dass irgendwie eine eine Überweisung zwischen Banken in Deutschland immer noch einen Tag dauert, ähm gibt's da vielleicht auch technische einen Verbesserungsbedarf, selbst wenn's am Ende weiter zentral gesteuert ist, Zentralbankgeld ist.
Ja. Aber am Ende hat man quasi einen Account bei der Zentralbank, so.
Wahrscheinlich.
Weil letzten Endes ist es ja nix anderes als das ja tja.
Heißt am Ende ist irgendwie nicht so richtig was bei rausgekommen bei dieser ganzen Krypto-Geldgeschichte, außer einer ganzen Mengen Glücksritter, die damit jetzt irgendwie Geld verdienen. Und natürlich ist es.
Mhm. Viel heiße Luft im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, genau, sodass man davon ausgehen kann, dass es halt irgendwann auch einfach so nicht weitergeht. Es sei denn dem Ganzen Geschehen steht halt irgendwann auch nochmal ein realer Wert.
Entgegen. Und der zeichnet sich derzeit zumindest noch nicht so richtig ab, habe ich den Eindruck.
Mhm. Ja das würde ich ganz genauso sehen. Also ich bin gespannt. Äh ich ich plane dann schon mal für zweitausenddreiunddreißig, Teil drei. Äh dieser Folge.
Wo wir dann unsere Aussagen und unsere Skepsis dann noch mal äh überprüfen können.
Unsere Vorhersagen nach nochmal zehn Jahren äh uns wieder angucken,
tatsächlich rechne ich damit, dass äh die äh also viele dieser Bubbles zusammenbrechen insbesondere das was da im NFT-Markt passiert ist einfach weit jenseits von,
von Gut und Böse. Ähm dass auch die Währungskurse zusammenbrechen werden. Ich rechne damit, dass äh es äh Regulierungen geben wird für den Betrieb von von Mining Recks.
Blockchain wird einfach in äh in fünf oder zehn Jahren als Buzzer-Technologie verschwunden sein. Das ist so ein bisschen wie objektorientiert und Korba in den Neunzigern.
Mhm. Ja, das denke ich auch. Also es ist zumindest so als politisches äh,
Ist es halt eigentlich jetzt schon tot, weil man sieht ja, dass da irgendwie einfach nix bei rauskommt, ne.
Genau.
Gut, aber damit ist jetzt nicht die Vorhersage verknüpft irgendwie so morgen brechen diese ganzen Kryptogeldmärkte äh zusammen, weil da ist halt derzeit einfach noch sehr viel die also da da ist noch viel Potenzial für mehr heiße Luft.
So, es gibt einfach so viel Aufregung und so viel Gehalte, du hast es ja selber jetzt schon gerade äh äh gesagt. So jetzt fangen sie schon an irgendwie zu
plakatieren, das Ganze äh äh erreicht, also sozusagen so ein Marktschreierischen Level, der eben dann auch das Internet schon verlässt, so Fernseh,
et cetera
halt jetzt hier äh das große Geld versprechen im Prinzip so eine Heilsbringerschaft wieder wie auch Lotto ja so nach dem Motto du musst hier nur dein Geld reinlegen und dann bist du irgendwie der Geilste, hast du diesen absurden Film irgendwie über dieses Kryptoland
gesehen, der seit ein paar Tagen durch das Internet geistert, also äh schaut euch das an. Das ist halt einfach.
Dann merkst du auch, was was in dieser Krypto-Szene auch kulturell schiefgeht. Ja, also so eine so eine männlich dominierte,
Protzermentalität, die irgendwie einfach von so ewigen Luxus ausgeht und,
darüber mit so einem mit so einer Bling-Bling-Attitüde versucht irgendwie Leute andocken zu lassen, die in irgendeiner Form auch irgendwie Teil des,
des des tollen Trends sein wollen, die da irgendwie drin glänzen und reich werden und irgendwie über ihre
Karibik äh Insel oder in dem Fall ist das glaube ich eine Insel irgendwo auf Fidschi sein. Äh ja mit irgendwie einen äh angeblich äh nachhaltigen Lamborghini irgendwie über die diese Trauminsel.
Es es ist so bezaubernd. Die haben die haben ja nicht mal Geschmack. Das ist so eine Katastrophe.
Das kommt noch dazu, ja also es ist es ist Geschmacksbefreiheit und es ist vor allem auch
eine wirklich aggressive Stimmung. Also man merkt das ja auch, äh wirst du sicherlich auch schon erfahren haben, ne. Also wenn man sich dann auch mal so in Netzen äh ähm
dazu kritisch äußert und einfach so diese Probleme mal aufzählt, wie wir das jetzt hier auch getan haben.
Hat man dann also auch wirklich sofort so ein ein ein Tross von äh völlig überdrehten Verteidigern,
an der Backe, ja, also die aufgeblasen, dann äh verschiedene,
dieser Punkte äh nach vorne stellen, so dieses so ja
dann gibt es irgendwie zwei Personen, die können mit Spenden nicht unterstützt werden, ja, was so vorhin auch schon gesagt hast oder es gibt halt Leute in
in China, die jetzt sozusagen äh in der Lage sind über über Kryptowährungsflüsse äh sich vielleicht ein so einen digitalen Lifestyle zu erarbeiten, wie man das halt im Westen äh derzeit auch kann über verschiedene Systeme. So nur das sind halt einfach die Ausnahmen und die Regeln ist halt einfach
Geld verdient wird, dadurch dass halt neues Geld in dieses System reingepumpt wird und die Leute pumpen deshalb sehr
Geld da rein, weil sie denken, dass es mehr wird, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass auch andere Leute auch noch Geld rein
und deswegen werden jetzt Anzeigen geschaltet. Deswegen wird äh noch mehr Hype gemacht, noch mehr Luxusversprechen gemacht, noch mehr Gedöns äh in die Welt gemalt. Was ist denn nun eigentlich alles theoretisch sein könnte und welche äh,
Heilsversprechung sozusagen da auch als nächstes noch am Horizont auftaucht. Nur real.
Ist es halt auf der einen Seite nichts. Es ist halt nichts. Es löst keine Probleme, die wir haben,
schafft aber eine ganze Menge neuer Probleme, die wir gerne nicht haben wollen, wie vor allem den,
Energieverbrauch, der immer weiter ansteigt und was das Letzte ist, was wir derzeit wirklich gebrauchen können und äh insofern,
ist halt die Frage, inwiefern man das gesellschaftlich noch mittragen soll nur für sozusagen die die Dollars in den Augen weniger hier äh wieder so viel
zu opfern und ich denke, das ist halt auch etwas, was in in in der politischen Diskussion ankommen muss,
es hier nichts ist, wo man mitreiten muss, sondern dass es eigentlich eher etwas ist, was als,
Das ist ein Problem, da müssen wir uns drum kümmern, ähm angesehen werden sollte.
In der Tat in der Tat. Also hoffen wir, dass äh auch die deutsche Politik da zur Besinnung kommt und äh ihre ganzen Blockchain-Projekte mal mit der Lupe beleuchtet. Muss das wirklich sein?
Genau.
Nein.
Genau. Alright. Dann würde ich sagen, können wir vielleicht Teil zwei äh hier erst mal äh abschließen, ob's jetzt wirklich elf Jahre dauert bis zum nächsten Resümee, werden wir dann sehen Andreas?
Es hängt ein bisschen von den Ereignissen ab, ja.
Ja, ja, genau. Man weiß es ja nicht. Also vielleicht äh passiert ja noch irgendwas äh Tolles und wir werden völlig ähm vom Gegenteil überzeugt. Allein es zeichnet sich äh äh derzeit noch nicht so richtig ab.
Alright, dann sage ich erstmal vielen Dank.
Waren wir ein Vergnügen.
Ja und das äh war's dann hier von mir äh von CAE in der zweihundertvierundzwanzigsten Ausgabe und äh irgendwann geht's wieder äh weiter. Bis dahin sage ich tschüss und.